in this ios development course you will
learn how to create a netflix clone app
using swift 5. omer who teaches this
course is an ios developer and excellent
instructor
what is going on guys this is hamr and
today we're going to be starting a new
series here on youtube where we are
going to be building netflix clone from
scratch using swift 5.
as you can see here
the
clone that we're going to be building is
the exact same replica of the netflix
application as you can see here there's
a list a bunch of lists of trending
movies trending tvs popular movies and
upcoming movies and one of my favorites
of all time that's operated where you
can see here the shoshank redemption and
godfather i really like these movies
and in today's video we're going to be
building this as a final product
um as you can see here you can either
play or download you can even long press
any title where it gives you this cool
animation and option to download
basically when you click download it's
going to be added to this list
um also we have here
a tab bar where we can actually
navigate through a list for um
tabs where we have here for example a
coming soon tap where it gives you a
list for the upcoming um movies and
tv series and all that kind of stuff and
one of my favorite features that we're
going to be building is the top search
where we are going to be able to search
for
our favorite movies like harry potter
and whatever movies that you like we
have a downloads list
um also
when you press
when you press or tap on any title of
those it's going to be
taking you directly to the official
trailer for the movie you're gonna be
having um a controller view where it
displays the trailer itself the title of
the um the movie
and also you're gonna have um you know
like a brief about what is this is
really about like you can read this
after finding a host barry you know the
rest um you can just go back in here
and
yes this is what we are going to be
building as you can see here also the
navigation bar scrolls with the table
view and scrolls back but it sticks to
the top when it reaches certain point
so let's just start by creating a new
xcode project
we can select app
let's call that netflix
and make sure to take storyboard and
swift because these are the things that
we're going to be using building this
application
hit next and choose your download your
installation folder
so uh first of all i'm not going to be
working with storyboards so let's just
first go ahead and get rid of those
you can click on main
move to trash
then click on the info plus file scene
configuration
and
we can
delete the storyboard name
um one more thing here
let's just
hit the netflix clone
app we'll just go ahead
and
hit shift command f let's type main
uh let's just select the first one over
here and one more time just search for
main this is the fastest way you can do
it actually so over here you can see ui
kit main storyboard we can delete that
as well and
right now 100 we got rid of the
storyboards
so right now let's just go ahead to our
scene delegate file let's just
configure that so that we can work
without these storyboards
uh we're going to be name renaming this
to
a windows scene
okay and then using this variable over
here the window we're going to be
assigning new window for our application
to be running on so let's just go ahead
and type window
um
is equals to ui
window
initialize that with the frame
um
we can see here we can say um
window scene dot coordinate space no
bounds
um next thing you need to write is
window
dot window scenes window scene
um third and um the third thing is
window
dot root view controller is going to be
our view controller over here so let's
just
make a new instance of that
and last but not least window don't make
key invisible
so what this
basically means is that we're going to
be assigning this view controller to um
to be the root view controller for our
application window
so um
okay so let's just go ahead and see what
we're going to be building over here
let's just go ahead and open that
netflix app um i don't know why this is
all about
all right yeah okay
okay
so as you can see here uh we have our
home
um we have a tab bar here that we can
use to you know navigate between the
tabs
and let's just start by building this at
first
so um
let's go ahead and change that
name to you know main tab
bar view controller
because i like each view controller name
to be descriptive about what it does
in
you know
so let's just maintain bar view
controller let's just change that as
well to ui tab bar controller
and here we are going to be making this
as a starting point for our application
so let's just start
um change that one more time
let's just go ahead to our main tab bar
let's just make a sure everything is
working just fine
um
system yellow
i just
choose our simulator to be the latest
iphone 13 pro max and hit command r for
building run this
um you know as for the first time it's
going to be taking a little time until
it's installed oh it actually worked it
didn't take much time at all so as you
can see here
um
we've changed the view
background color of the main tab bar to
system yellow and over here you can see
it's a little bit dimmed because this is
actually our tab bar that we're going to
be using
okay
so
um we have all this let's just create
here a folder
let's call that controllers oh no
something's not right i'm
okay controllers
and let's
um
create a new
file over here
we're going to select the coco touch
class
um uiviewcontroller let's just call that
home
press create
delete all of that we're not going to be
needing that
and
let's just background color
red
let's create another one here
goku touch the same thing
search or i believe it's going to be
upcoming
up
coming view controller
okay
hit create
delete all of that um let's just select
another color for it view background
color is going to be
green um
i'll just create the
the third one which we have here i
believe it's search
new controller
okay let's
do the same thing basically development
is all about making
um the same pattern over and over again
so view the background color
uh let's just give it um pink system
pink okay and last but not least um
one more coco touch glass which is going
to be downloads
um let's give it a new color as well so
that we can identify it once we press on
it
so let's
get that um i don't know what we
blew
okay
so
we have here our main tab bar that is
going to be having four tabs to press on
so let's just
initialize that
so let vc1 is equal to ui navigation
controller root view controller is going
to be home
and
okay pc2
ui navigation controller road
upcoming
one more time
p3 equals to ui navigation controller
okay
search
select vc4 is equal to ui navigation
controller you
okay
and if you ask me why the hell we
uh added those controllers to a ui
navigation controller okay basically
um as you can see here let's just go
ahead to the application that we're
going to be building
here's a navigation controller and once
we click on any of those it's going to
take you to another
controller that's going to be pushed on
the
current one so basically this is why we
are adding each one of those to its own
navigation controller let's go back to
here
okay
um
we want first to change
the image
or let's just go ahead and set
view controllers over here let's just
create an array of our vcs so vc1
vc2 pc3 and pc4 and maybe let's just set
that to true
okay let's just go ahead and build and
run this and let's see what we've got
all right i can see here that we've
already uh showing our
first vc
um let's just
press over here and as you can see
immediately we can change
between
the uh tab bars over there so why don't
we add um an image for each one of those
so that we can easily identify those
we're going to be using sf symbols
um
it's a tool available on the apple
website
as you can see here we can search for
example for house
um
we're going to be using this
as our home
uh tab bar image so
let's just go ahead and type the eco vc1
the tab bar item.image is equals to ui
image
system name
house
we're going to be making the same thing
over here templar item
image
ui image and i believe
this one name was um
[Music]
what was this i
really have no idea but let's just um
play
um yeah play circle i believe this is
the one so we can copy the name over
here
we can paste the name over there
and boom
vc3
tab or image
okay
ui image
system name i believe this is called
magnum
um fine
glass
um yeah that stands for the search yes
and vc4 tab or item dot image
is equals to
image system name i want to have
something that um
okay
something for the downloads i believe it
was called
um
arrow
online something like this
we can use that to search oh yeah arrow
arrow down to line
so let's just copy that name
let's add that name over here
and
boom that's it let's just build and run
this
and
it's easy
as this
like yes it's really really simple
as you can see here
um also we can um
right pc one tab all right and content
color i believe
um i don't believe it's number one
vc1 dot
title
home if you see two dot title
um coming
vc3 though title
search
um i believe it's stop search
um let's just make sure that we're
naming that correctly
okay
um home coming soon top searches and
downloads okay home
coming soon
just write that correctly
boom building one
and yes we have all of this over here
um i believe one last thing that we need
to do is just um
let's just
set that to
system
background
and i want to actually set the system
background to all of the controllers
over here because you know
those colors are going to make me blind
somewhere
um
okay let's just go ahead and build and
run that one more time
what do we have here okay
we have our tab bars
um successfully made i believe that we
just need to change the thin color for
each and every one of those let's just
go ahead
in the main
okay tab bar
dot
then color dot label i believe that's
that's the one i'm very sorry yes and
let's just go ahead and try that
um
with the dark mode and the light mode
and as you can see here it's all
working
so um that's it for today's video um
in the next video we're going to be
starting working in the home view
controller we're going to be um setting
our table view so that it can look
something like this
um as you can see here just let me give
you a brief because this video is
getting too long
um
here's a table view that's the header
for the table view and each cell for the
table view is going to be a collection
view itself where we can use
to horizon horizontally scroll
through our movies and as you can see
here uh it's really really efficient
because it doesn't load
um the whole list at once it or it only
does that when you reach
the end like this so yes
and not all the table view cells load at
once so yeah it's pretty much efficient
so so let's just start the hem bite i'm
a private let
home feed table this is going to be a
table view
and i'm going to use the anonymous
closure pattern
let's initialize our table
to be ui table view
let's register um
a normal cell for now
of course we're going to customize
ourselves
so let's just type ui table view cell
make sure to type dot cell because we
want the type itself
and let's register that with our
reusable identifier as cell
and we can return our table right now
so that's done right there
let's just add this table view to our
view
and also we just need to give that
um
a frame so that we can view that on our
screen
and also make sure to type super the
view to lay out some views
okay we just need to give that a frame
and that frame is going to
be equal to view bounce so it's just
going to cover the whole bounds of our
screen
um
and also we can um let's just make sure
everything is
done correctly and hit command r to
build and run this and view that on our
simulator right there
so as you can see there there's nothing
actually on the screen and this is what
this that's because actually the table
view is still empty it needs to have
some data in order to be able to
dequeue some cells and those cells
should have all the data that you want
um let's just go ahead and do this by
typing home video table and set the data
source and the delegate protocols
for
the table view
home page table the data source and
those are the two protocols that we need
to confirm to in order for our table
view to work properly
okay so um
let's just do that in an extension so
that we can keep our file clean ui table
view delegate and also i need the ui
table view data source
we just need to um
implement those two methods which is the
number
of rows inside each section let's just
say for example that we need 20 rows
um and also
the other
method is going to be cell 4 row and
this is a delegate method that tells
that
table view um
actually which
which um which cell that we're going to
dequeue for each row
so um let's just type let's cell is
equals to table view
dot dq with reusable identifier i really
like
how switch um sorry how swift language
is actually architectured as you can see
there like it it feels like you're
reading just english hey table view dq
reusable cell with the identifier cell
for index path this is pure english guys
and now let's return that cell and just
for testing
purposes let's just type um text label
dot text and make be sure guys that this
is going to be deprecated in the future
um
hello world
okay
this is going to uh work i believe let's
just
uh test that and type hit
command r
and let's hope yeah it works as you can
see there
we have our table view setup and
we are going
we're getting a little bit closer to
what we want to do at the end time
prompts here
okay
so um
as you can see here let's just go ahead
and view the real deal
um
that part is the uh the header for our
table view and starting from there this
is going to be a cell and that
that's going to be a cell as well
okay so what's this this is going to
be a header for each section oh wait a
minute so basically we have two kinds of
headers yes that's correct basically we
have a
header for each section
and also we have a header and that's um
separated from the others and that's for
the whole table
that's the really cool part about table
view that you can assign um a header for
each section or the header for the table
if you want and this is exactly what
we're going to do and we're going to
leverage the um the delegate methods for
disable view to do
exactly that
so let's say here for example that i
want my cell
to be a height of
200
and also um
height for section
yes and let's just return 40
and let's hit command r and build and
run and see what we get
okay so as you can see here
um there is the
section header
and also each cell is um
is 200
uh points
in height
uh let's just make that a little bit
easier to see let's type cell dot
background color let's just give that an
arbitrary color for now let's say
red
and as you can see here this is our cell
this is a cell this is a cell and
there's a slightly change in the color
here which is basically the separator
between each cell
okay so what do we need to do right now
um
basically
we are going to create um
a custom a custom cell that we're going
to be using here in our table view cell
and uh since this
project is going to be based on the
design pattern of the mvvm which is the
model view view model
um we have our controllers already so
let's just go ahead and create a new
folder um new group in here let's call
that
reviews
um
any other group is new models
one more time here um
what else do we have
models
okay
and because i have an lcd maybe
so
yeah model view view models controllers
this is the exact
um
way i'd like actually to
you know organize my project
um
let's just go ahead and
[Music]
yeah let's leave that right there for a
moment let's just go ahead and make
resources
folder
and also one for our managers and i'll
get to that
later okay
so for now let's just
create a new view
right here let's just go ahead and
create new file
um
coco touch class and
right there you can just type ui table
review cell
and in here i'm going to write um
give that a name of collection
view table view cell and i'll tell you
exactly why i'm
naming this um
like that because i want each cell to
have a collection view itself and by
reading this only i can see that i have
a collection view inside the table view
cell and the table view cell actually is
going to be the type
of the um
of this file
so just hit next i'm going to create
this in the view i'll just
delete all of that because i'm not going
to need that and
i just type
static
light
identifier
and it's that is going to be
collection view
table view cell and basically the
identifier is the same as the one that
we used for registering the normal set
that we registered at the beginning of
this part uh it was we named that cell
however this one is going to be called
collection view table view cell
and also let's just initialize that
super dot in it
style
and reusable identifier and make sure
to also
um
implement that angelizer as well
fail error and leave that as it is
okay
so right now let's just
um
get that
for its content view a background color
so system pink for example
yes i like that color a lot and let's
just go here
and
type collection view table usl
and also copy that one more time as well
in here
and
dot identifier this is how we register
our custom view cell
let's go right there in the cell for
row method
and okay let's just delete that i'm
going to teach you how to write that
properly without going into errors but
just type guard let cell is equals to
table view dot dq with reusable
identifier which in our case here is
collection
view table view cell dot identifier
for index path as
um collection view it will use cell
else we just need to return a normal
view
a normal table view cell actually and
right now let's just return that cell
and let's just hit command r to building
one and let's see what we have right
there
okay so basically this is
our
um
this is our table and as you can see
here each cell is a system pink and
right now
um you might ask
okay so we have this each cell and it's
200 points in height
why do we not see why don't we see the
height for the um for the header as a
matter of fact when we initialized that
table view we did not specify that we're
going to be having headers
and we can easily do that
using this so let's just give that
a zero frame right now
because we have already initialized the
frame inside the view the layout some
views method and the important part here
is just to
specify the slide of this ui table view
to be grouped
basically groups is going to give your
table view the style the same as uh
apple uses
inside settings app
so let's build around that one more time
and let's see the difference in here
okay
a height
of um
40 pixels
and
yeah you can also argue with me
about okay
i thought that you're going to have
header for each section well as you can
see here we're only having one section
and inside each section
there is 20 rows so we want to um
to fix that
so let's implement another method in
here um that means this method is called
um number of sections
and instead we're going to return the 20
right here and inside each section i
just need one row let's
hit command and r to build and run and
let's see that
so as you can see here we started to get
a little bit closer to the final product
that we want to design using ui kit
which is our netflix
um design
okay
one more thing that we need to do here
is um giving each one of those a
collection view cell so that we can
actually have
a placeholder where we can use to put
our
labels and movie titles and movie
posters in it so let's just go ahead to
our collection views cell table view
cell hidden here
and let's
define a new connection view cell using
the same anonymous closure pattern right
there so private let
collection view
this is going to be
a ui collection view
and
let's just
go ahead and make that so the first
thing that we need to do is
um
using the analysis closure pattern so
that collection view is equal to ui
collection view
and
for the frame right now it's going to be
zero and let's just initialize that with
a layout which is layout which is going
to yellow us because layout hasn't been
uh initialized yet or it has no idea
what is layout
but don't worry
just return our collection view right
there and over here let's just go ahead
and define this layout
and that is going to be
ui collection
view flow
layout
we can type layout dot
um
scroll directions going to be horizontal
because as you can see in the main
networks app it's um
it's the direction that we use to you
know navigate through each category so
we have layout scroll directions going
to be horizontal and this is going to
be layout in here one more thing like
the table view because table views and
ui collection views is pretty much like
we just need to register in a cell in
here
okay
and for this i'm going to um type ui
collection view cell
dot cell because i see you know we would
just need the type
and we are going to um give that an
arbitrary cell name right now which is
going to be so
okay we just need to add this to our
content view
collection view and let's also conform
to those two protocols that allows us to
display pictures and our data inside the
collection view
so just um
type collection view
don't delegate it's going to be self
collection view the data source is going
to be self as well
and before xcode us because we haven't
conformed to those
protocols
let's um
let's do that right there ui collection
view
uh
delegate
ui collection view data source
and
the best part is that it's pretty much
the same as the um
the table the table view
um
i just
um
add the
methods that we're going to use so
basically sell for item and also number
of um items inside the section let's
just return
that to b10
and for that let's just let's sell it's
gonna be a collection view on dq with a
reusable identifier
cell
for index path
return cell
okay
cell
the
background color um
we should say green
i don't know why but i like green
so let's build and run this and see what
we
get okay
nothing in here
why
okay
um
let's
i oh my god this isn't gonna be green
okay
let's see what happened
okay
so
we have our cells
and inside each cell
yeah we forgot to give that a frame
okay
so as you see guys i don't uh cut inside
videos and pretend everything is going
to be working as fine
um i'm just coding this live so that you
can see how we can debug our app so that
we can identify the problem and fix it
and you know the rest yeah so lay out
some views
super lay out some views and
i want my collection view to be
the entire body of the cell
so i'll just give that
a collection view about frame examples
to content view the balance
and let's build around that and test if
that works
okay as you can see here each cell
is actually working
um
it's colored in
yeah this is the system background color
um we're gonna fix that later but as you
can see here this is not the layout i
want for each
column i want the each item of this to
take the entire height of the cell
and
okay you asked me how we can do that
actually it's very easy we can specify
that over here layout
item size easy size
and let's
um give that um
a width and a height
so let's say for example i just need to
give um 144 of the widths
and um 200 for the height
let's just run and see what we get
and as you can see here we are getting
closer and closer to
the final product that we want and as
you can see here also that each one of
those uh cells um
are independent of the each other and it
has the horizontal scrolling
functionality enabled by default
why because we said that right there
okay
one more thing
uh we just want to um you know add the
header
for our table view
um okay so let's just go ahead in our um
home view controller
and
yes
let's go here in the view that load
and let me just go ahead and type home
feed table dot
table
header view and inside here we're going
to define our
ui view
frame
cgrect
x00 and let's just give that the um
the width
of the um
of the view and for height let's say for
example i just need 450
okay and let's just uh build and run
this i'm just testing that it's going to
work and yes as you can see here we're
going to be using this
for our hero view controller it's not
going to be a view controller actually
it's just going to be a ui view but i'm
not going to create this with this
method right here
um
we're going to make a separate view
right there so we can separate the
functionality for each view so that each
view and it's gonna be working on its
own okay
what else do we need to do okay
um
i guess that's it for this video because
i believe this video is getting too long
in the next video i'm going to
modify the header for each section
basically we're going to have four
sections one for
the top recent movies top rated movies
and all that kind of stuff
and also um i think if if if we can make
that happen
uh in proper time we can you know
start working on the hero
as well
so first things first we're going to go
to our view folder
and let's create a new file here just
tap a new file
goku touch class
then we're going to create a new ui view
and now let's call that um hero header
ui view
okay so let's tap create
and now let's just delete all of that
kind of stuff because we're not going to
need that so
um
we want to um
give that a frame
and
inside that frame we're going to assign
um three things the first thing is the
ui image view
um and the other things is the two
buttons where um
one of them is going to be the download
button and the other one is going to be
the play button so let's just start by
initializing this
with a frame of course
and just for you know the frame is going
to be assigned when initializing this
view so let's just go ahead and type
super dot net
frame
and the most important thing just to um
avoid any error just import the required
initializer
just type fail error and then we're
ready to go here okay so as i told you
the first thing that we need to
implement here is going to be um
an image view that's going to contain
our header
so
just type
hero
image view
this is going to be a ui image view
let's use the anonymous closure
let
um
image view is able to the ui image view
and let's return that image view
and before we return that um
let's see here what we need to do um
yeah
so let's just type
imageview.content mode it's going to be
fill
and scale aspect fill to be exact
let's type also
imageview.clipse 2 pounds
and that's going to be true so we avoid
um
overflow
and yeah that's it
so basically um and also you know what
okay so we don't need to be using uh
constraints here because it's going to
be very simple actually
so um
let's just add this sub view here
and we can use the
layout function
layout view
just to give that a frame
um
i just type hero image view the frame is
gonna be equal to bounce
and um
one more things that we need to do
is that i've downloaded this poster for
this movie uh we're just going to use it
as uh for testing purposes so let's just
go ahead um and you know what you can
just go and download any picture or any
photo that you want from the internet
you can use the unsplash website for
downloading free pictures or even you
can just go ahead and grab any movie
poster you can add the to add this to
the assets folder just
right click here new image assets and
just give it a name as
you can see here i gave it the name hero
image and i just place it right there um
i'm not going to go exactly in details
what are the difference between the 1x
2x and the 3x right now because this is
not our focus right now let's just go
back in here
let me just type
imageview.image and we're going to use
that image
as you can see here i'm typing ui image
named
and let me guess uh what did we call it
yeah hero image we can actually copy
that name so that we um we're not going
to be prone to any errors
and just paste that name and right here
okay so basically
this is our um
header view and it's completed right now
let's just go ahead to our home view
controller
and as you can see here we're assigning
the table header view to um an arbitrary
ui view let's just delete that
and type header view
let's initialize that right here
um
let
header
view
it's gonna be equals to um
hero
header view and we're going to
initialize that with a frame
and our frame is going to be a c direct
let's place that at 0 0 and as you might
uh guess the width of the header is
going to take the entire width of the
application so let's just go ahead and
type view the bounds dot width
and the other one
i might give that a height of maybe 450
points for now
and let me just go ahead and build and
run this using command r and let's see
what we got so far
okay so basically we are set um we have
our poster here and
second thing i wanted to do is that um i
wanted to give that um
this effect of the um you know fading
out so we're going to utilize the
gradient
and it's going to be um very tricky if
you give it a thought for at first but
trust me um i'm going to try to do my
best here to um to explain it and to be
honest it's really that simple it's not
that hard to be honest so let's just go
ahead here
in our um
initializer and say um add a gradient
and we are going to create this function
right now so
let's just go here um i might go there
private
thunk
add gradient
and
okay so here it goes so we just need uh
to add um
a cg
uh or see i'm not from i don't remember
exactly let me just go ahead and type
let
gradient
layer
it's to be c
a
gradient layer i guess that's the one
um let me choose the gradient layer
colors we're going to assign two colors
in here okay so what what's the effect
that we're seeking for so basically we
wanna utilize two colors what are those
colors okay whenever you see a fading
out effect so basically the gradient
effect or the gradient colors uh we'll
be we're going to be using to apply this
effect is the clear
and whatever the system background is so
let's say for example let me just grab
the simulator over here so basically
over here i want the color to be clear
which is absence of colors or whatever
color that you might choose however it's
going to be alpha 0 so basically a
transparent color here so that we can
see the poster and as we go down i
wanted this color to um
become more black until it blends with
this black as you can see here so um let
me just go ahead and um and type that
and i hope that's going to make sense so
let me just go ahead and type ui color
dot clear
this is the color that we want and we
just need the cg color value of it
the other one
is going to be ui color
dot
system background
um cg color
okay
um
the next thing that we need to do is
just we need to add this sub layer
um
to our ui view which is going to be um
by using um
layer
dot add sub layer
and it's going to be gradient layer
okay so let's build and run this and see
what we get
all right so basically it's not working
yet
and that's because we forgot to
give the gradient layer a frame so
basically we're going to give it a frame
for the entire bounds over here um it's
really simple
to be honest gradient layer dot frame is
going to be equal to bounce let me just
um build and run this
and yes as you can see here um we have
our clear
color here which is basically a color
with an alpha which is going to be equal
to zero so basically it's a transparent
color
that gives you ability to see through
and the other thing here um the black
color
which is because our system right now is
using the dark mode so it's gonna be a
whole black color over here um i'm not
sure if i just try to toggle the dark
mode with the light mode it's gonna work
um it's not working yet um
okay so basically it's not working
because um the system background color
right now is not responsive so basically
when we initialize this header view it
just uh it just so that the color which
has been used right now
for the system background color is going
to be black so it assigned the color
black and when we change it back again
to the light mode so basically it has no
idea that the color of the system has
been changed so we're going to
look at that
later on this is not our main focus
right now so let's just go back to our
um
[Music]
to our dark mode over here and let's
just go ahead and add our two buttons
that we're going to be using for either
play or download this title okay so let
me just go head over here let me just
type private let
um
play button and that's going to be equal
to a type of ui button
let me just use the same
uh pattern which is going to be the
anonymous closure that button is going
to be ui button
dot text
or set text i believe set title yeah
um
which is going to be play
for normal
return button and let me also um
button
dot border
color
is going to be
system background i believe
okay
new eye color system background
um not cg color
okay
um what else do we need to do yeah
button dot um border width
is going to be one for now
and um
yeah we are going to use constraints to
lay out this button perfectly so just
type button
dot
translate auto resizing masks into
constraints this is going to need to be
equal to false so that we can
use the constraints in here
so let me just go ahead
and um let's just add this sub view play
button right here
and i just want to create another
function here which is going to be named
apply
constraints
and we can
define this function over here private
func apply constraints
and let me just give that name let's
play
button constrains gonna be equal to an
array and let's just start by giving
that a constraint so that we can place
that button on our screen
so let's just type play button
dot leading anchor i'm not going to use
the left anchor because um some of you
guys may be from an arabic speaking
country um
you know for
arabic speaking countries and devices
that have the arabic um language set by
default um these languages
um basically they are read from right to
left it's not as english like you read
english from english from left to right
i'm sorry
so basically we are saying that for
english based um devices we're going to
assign the play button on the leading
anchor which is in our case gonna be on
the left okay
uh but for devices that have an arabic
based language um
the leading anchor is going to be on the
right
um it's really good practice if you want
to make your app as much global as you
wanna um
as you want so it you know
it uh behaves differently with each
language so uh we're going to constrain
that
um
to the leading anchor
and i just wanted to give that like a
margin of um 25 points from the left
um and then i'm going to say another
constraint which is going to be um
bottom anchor and it's going to be
constrained to the bottom
anchor and i wanted to give that also a
margin however um
when we uh i want this margin to be uh
by negative so that
uh it doesn't count from the uh the
point of the bottom constraints and move
downward i wanted this play button to
move upwards so i'm going to give that
maybe negative 20.
and
let's just activate this constraint so
nslayoutconstrain.activate
playbutton constraints
i guess um
we're done over here let's just type
command on ours let's build around this
and see what we get
yes as you can see here we have our play
button
as you can see here
it's um it has
if
you look slightly you can see here
the
the border but let's just
go here and let's change that color
maybe to white so it's easier to see
wait a minute
ui colored y dot cg color
i believe that would work
okay so basically here's our play button
uh it's 25 points from the left 25
points
from the uh bottom
we're going to fix that
but not now we just need to get things
working
um maybe we
we can give that another constraint here
play button dot width anchor
constraint is going to be equal to
constant and let me just give that maybe
100 points
um so it gets wider yes um we're
starting to
getting something here
um
let me just go ahead and maybe increase
this to be 125 maybe
um too much let's just
give that 90 and as you can see here we
don't have like an exact file that we
can get our
margins and
padding and all that kind of stuff with
so basically we're just uh trying uh
using the trial and error method so
basically this is how we get things done
working um in no time
so let me just go ahead and give that
maybe negative 50.
um
yes so um i want
to um
yes it's working fine for me to be
honest like i couldn't ask for more
um
let me just go ahead right now and add
the um
the download button so private let's
download
um buttons gonna be a type of ui button
basically we're just doing the same
things here
um i hope i can write correctly
let's button
it's gonna be ui button
essentialize that have an instance
button basically we're going to have the
same
things over here
so let's just copy and paste that
um
and to be honest there's no room for
error
um yeah basically we're going to use the
same stuff over here
and let's just
add this to our view add some view
download button
and then let's just um set new
constraints for that button as well so
let's download
one constraint
we're gonna be equal
array
um
download button
um leading anchor that constrains so
basically we can just reverse that into
the other direction so um maybe we can
use the
um trailing
anchor
and
[Music]
negative 90.
okay download button the bottom
anchor the constraints gonna be equals
to the bottom anchor
negative 50. um and also the same width
is going to be used so download button
over here with anchor that constrains um
100 points
and let me just go ahead and activate
this constraints as well
download button constraints and let me
just build and run this and see what we
have
um
okay
so
clearly it's not right something is
wrong over here
um
let me see what we have
so um
i believe there's something wrong over
here
um
okay
oh yeah let me just go ahead and
trailing
anchor over here i believe this will
solve the issue
and yes so i believe it's slightly
um
you know shifted towards the left but
okay we just need to get things uh done
really quickly
um
we can just give that
something like um will
look a little bit better upon the layer
dot border
um radius maybe
corner radius
it's gonna be five
let's just see what we have here
oh yeah it's going to be better
if we used um
a corner radius or something
okay
and maybe just give that a little bit
more
of
points here to use as width
okay
so
yeah
that seems nice that looks nice okay
so basically we have here our um button
so um
maybe we can also
make that 70 and this is also 70. we
just need to give them a little bit of
margin between
themselves um yeah i believe that looks
okay and let me define a function over
here
okay so
let's just call this function configure
navbar
okay
we can copy that
just declare a private function over
here with the same name of course
and
okay so basically what we want we just
need to add the netflix logo so we can
just go ahead open google let's just
type netflix
logo png so basically we need that with
a transparent uh
background
um yeah that's the one that's the one i
downloaded so you can just go ahead into
your assets over here
right click new image set and then drag
and drop it
as
as i did over here so basically i call
this
netflix logo and that's the name i'm
going to use to
initialize my image over here
so let me just go back to my home view
controller
um let me just
get the grab the image first so
basically var
image is going to be ui image
named
netflix
logo and some of you might ask why did i
initialize that in a variable not in a
constant uh well
bear with me for just a second i'll tell
you exactly why we need to do that so
basically um let's just go ahead and
type navigation item dot left bar button
item and this is going to be equal to a
ui bar plan item
and let me choose this one
so basically i'm going to add my image
over here the slide is going to be done
target self and the action is nil for
now
okay so let's build and run this and see
what we have
okay so
as you can see here i have the netflix
logo over here but something seems to be
incorrect over here
um well basically we just need to modify
or configure this image itself before
adding it to the nav bar and that that's
why actually i have initialized the
image with a variable because we are
going to further modify the image so let
me just go ahead and type image
it's going to be the image
dot
with render mode
dot always original so this is how we
force our um
ios system just to use the image as it
is so let's just build and run this one
more time and let's see what we have
okay easy busy so we have the netflix
logo over here every single everything
seems to be working just as fine um and
as you can see here whenever you tap on
it you know uh it dims a little bit
darker so
yeah that looks cool okay
so the next thing is that um there's
also as you can see here navigation item
there is
left bar button item and with some logic
you can
did use that um
we have also right but right bar button
item okay
but this is not what we want actually we
want items and
fortunately enough
uh basically apple just gave us
it
in a really simple way so basically we
can type navigation item dot right
button and as you can see here we have
right bar button item if you want to add
just a single
button or a single image
whatever you want and the other one here
is a one with an s so basically it takes
an array
and let's add our
um let's add our buttons inside this
array so basically what we're going to
do is just we're going to type ui part
button item
let's initialize that
with an image
okay
so for this image i'm going to
initialize that with a system image
let me just go ahead and type that as a
person and
if you ask me from where i knew that
there is an icon uh inside the system
which is called person so basically
there is a tool offered by apple you can
just go ahead into apple website or just
google uh sf symbol
it's a dual provided by apple which
gives you all of this
pre-defined icons you can just search
for the icon that you want and copy the
name from here
let's say for example i just need the
person and as you can see here i have
person person that failed personal
circle you get the idea okay so let me
just go back and type person
my style is going to be done
target self and the action is nil for
now and let me add another button over
here ui bar button item
okay
image
i'm going to initialize that
with um play dot
all
rectangle
style
it's gonna be done target self and the
action is also nil for now
and we can build and run and let's see
what we get
so basically um everything seems to be
working fine i want to have this
maybe whenever we tap on this button we
should be um
represented by the coming soon uh tab
uh i haven't decided yet so um and yes
that's the one we're going to be using
for our profile
i'm not sure actually i'm going to be
working on the profile controller right
now i guess i don't want to
you know
make this tutorial or this series too
long but
i'll just see what i decide
okay so um one thing i also wanted to
change um let's type navigation
controller navigation bar the tin color
and i want to set this to white
and if i build and run this one more
time and i can see here i get the
buttons color to be
changed to white actually
okay
so everything seems to be working fine
except for one thing
basically as you can see here the
navigation bar
um
it always sticks to the top
and it hides the content behind it well
for some of you that might be a good
design but i just wanted to stick with
the design from the
real netflix app
so um here's the thing
i'm going to implement an algorithm
which allows me to
push the navigation controller um
as soon as i reach the very top of the
screen here the
the navigation controller is going to be
pushed upwards until it gets disappeared
and whenever i pull down
uh i want to uh basically
uh leave the navigation button or i'm
sorry the navigation bar over here
sticks to the top
so let's just go ahead
down here
and let me implement this algorithm so
basically
a table view basically it's a scroll
view so it inherits the all the methods
that the scroll view have so basically
let's type scroll view that's crawl
and let me
type over here this um
maybe i'm not going to go into the
details of how this algorithm work but
i'm going to type it and as i'm typing
i'm going to explain what we have over
here
so basically um let's just
declare a new variable here let's call
that default offset
and let me get this from um
view dot safe area insets dot top so
basically this is going to be um the
offset of the top
uh safe inserts um of the screen okay so
basically uh it's not going to uh
to count as the notch is not there it's
going to count for the notch
um
okay so the other thing i wanted to get
is that um the offset that i wanted to
uh assign for the navigation bar so let
me just go ahead and um declare a new
very
constant over here basically it's on the
it's not a variable
um
we can call it
offset and this is going to be scroll
view dot content offset dot y
plus
default
offset
okay the next thing that we need to do
and it's very very easy if you don't
want to get into the details or
how this actually works behind the
scenes you can just copy it so basically
let's just type navigation
controller navigation bar dot transform
and
net i want to use um
this so basically we don't need to um
translate the navigation
uh bar uh in the x axis so basically
this is going to be one
and the behavior i just uh mentioned
whenever i pull down i just wanted uh to
have the navigation bar sticks uh to the
top so basically we're going to
implement this by typing minimum
and it's either going to be zero or
if the offset is negative so that means
we are um pushing
the navigation to top so basically let's
type negative
offset
let's build and run this
and let's see the result that we have
okay so first of all let me just pull
down
and as you can see here the navigation
bar sticks to the top but what happens
if i uh pull to the top
okay and as you can see here
exactly that's the behavior i want to
implement so basically let's pull down
one more time
let's pull in the other direction
perfect everything seems to be working
fine that's it
okay so uh since we completed our work
over here with the navigation
bar let's just go ahead and set our
um
set our
header titles over here so basically um
let's say for example let me just go
ahead and open the
the one that we should have
uh basically we have trending movies
trending tvs
popular upcoming movies top rated uh i
don't think i'm going to um
memorize all of that let me just
give me just a minute here
so basically um let's just go over here
and let's declare an array that's going
to hold our text or basically the string
for our header sections titles maybe so
let's just type let
header or sorry
section
titles
that's going to be um array of strings
and let me just start by typing um
trending movies
trending tv
all right let's just
give me a moment over here i'm going to
look at my second screen
um yeah we have popular
upcoming movies and top rated okay just
a minute okay let's type top um rated
and let's add one more
um item over here um upcoming movies
okay
so let's go down there
let's change the number of sections to
be um
titles section titles dot count
and over here let me just go ahead and
grab the um
the simulator one more time just a
second
okay so um
we have the popular oh yeah we forgot
the popular i believe
okay
just a second
popular
okay so trending movies popular trending
tvs upcoming movies and top rated and as
you can see here we're going to
initialize
um account number so basically this is
going to get the number of titles i've
added over here
and
yeah it's going to be dynamically
assigned
all right so let's add the titles for
each section
and just go over here type title
um title four header in section
and let's just return
um
section titles
index um i believe it's going to be yeah
it's going to be section
and this we're going to get this section
from here so basically let's build and
run this and see what we have
okay we have the everything set up right
now we have um
yes the number of sections are correct
is correct and as you can see here
trending movies popular trending tv and
the upcoming movies one thing that is
bothering me actually is the font it's
all uppercase over here
and
i don't believe the color is
really subtle like you can just see it
easily so let's just go ahead and
fix that
okay so basically what we need to do is
um to implement another method
so basically um it's just going to be um
will display
let me just go ahead and type that
correctly table
view
will display
header view
um we're going to get the header itself
for each section so let me just go ahead
and type guard let
header
okay
it's going to be
view
as
ui table
header
view
for review just a second else
return
and now we have an instance for our
header
so let me just go ahead and modify the
things that i needed to change so
basically let me type header
dot text
label
and
that means you know this warning means
that is going to be deprecated in the
future
however we just need to get things um
working right now
so um
since this is an optional let me just
type a question mark over here
dot
font
let me just go ahead and type system
font
of size 18
and let me just go ahead and type
semibolt
we want to give that header uh or that
text actually
a frame
so um
header
dot text label
dot frame
is going to be c direct
okay so we want the header
bounds
dot origin
dot x
and let me just give that like a margin
of 20 points from the left
we wanted to have the same
um y position so basically header pounds
um origin
dot y
and for width let's say
100 points
and the header is going to fill the
entire section
um so let's type header
dot bounds
dot height
let's build and run and see what we get
so far
okay so much better
um basically we have here um 20 points
from the left 18 points for the font and
the semi-bold so that we can see it much
better and now we get i guess we need to
change the color as well
so um let me just go ahead and type
header
dot text label
dot
um
text color
yeah that's the one
and assign that to white
much better much better to be honest
okay um
one more thing over here let me just
um
yeah everything seems to be working fine
um i believe i just need to um
[Music]
what do i need to do actually um okay
so i'm going to go ahead and type text
label
dot um text
and i just need to change that to a
header the text label
dot text
dot lowercase
and let me see what we have here
okay
um
i think it looks good
um
i just wanted to um
to capitalize the first letter uh maybe
in another video like i'm going to talk
a little bit more about extensions and
how we can take advantage of the
extensions to um to
shorten our code make it easier uh to
read and actually um yeah i wanted to
change the first letter over here to be
a capital letter instead of old small
okay so um i believe that's it for this
tutorial because it's getting too long
so
just to recap we worked on our
navigation bar over here we implemented
the scroll effect uh actually
we worked as well here to assign
a dynamic number of sections
it matches the sections that we have
over here we have set also the title for
each section
um yeah i guess that's it for this
tutorial
in the next one i believe we're going to
uh to start working with networks so
that we can fetch um some data over the
internet and um
you know have
actually uh posters of movies over here
let me just type in here in the search
bar dmdb
so basically that stands for the movie
database and that's the website that
we're going to be using for getting all
of our um movies and all that kind of
stuff that you can see here over the
screen so if you haven't signed up
already for this website it's really
simple you can just create your account
and once you're complete with that you
can just press over here and
go to the settings
and over here you can just tap on api
and as you can see here you get one of
the api keys that we're going to be
actually using for introducing ourselves
to the website so it's just like hey
website hey tmdb we're us so please
give us all the information that we need
so
we just need to copy that
and let's go back to xcode over here and
in the managers folder we created
earlier i'm going to create a new file
here it's going to be normal swift files
and i'm going to call that api color
and over here let's just create a class
let's just call that class api caller
inside that class i'm going to create a
shared instance i'm going to call this
shirt
and
yes we're complete over here so
basically we're going to use that shared
instance so that we can call all of the
methods that we're going to fill in here
later but for the sake of simplicity in
the future i'm going to create a new
struct over here i'm going to call that
constants
inside that i'm going to um create a new
console over here so let's just type
static let
api key
and let me just paste that key that we
got earlier from the tmddb website
so
um let's just go back over here and
let's open the documentation for the
website itself up to be honest it's well
written and you can just go through it
and see what you can get with this
database so let me just go ahead and
type trending movies i'm sorry trending
and as you can see here we have a method
it's also a get method
and it helps us to get the all the
trending movies tv and also persons if
you want to have like a tab for showing
the actors and the actresses and all
that kind of stuff you can just
tap on try out and as you can see here
basically there's an example of how you
might be using the website so let me
just copy that
let me just open a new tab and paste
that over here and basically this is
just a placeholder that we can delete
and instead we're just going to provide
the api key that we got earlier
so let me just do that
and as you can see here our request went
successfully and you can see here page
one results um
maybe there are you're familiar with the
spanish uh title which is la casa de
papel it's one of my favorite shows if
you want to watch it go ahead it's
airing right now on netflix
so um yes we have all the information
that we have over here um for example we
have the vote average 7.6 and all the
information for the um
for the titles that we're looking for so
so far so good so let's just go back to
xcode and start working here in our api
caller
i'm going to create a new function that
we're going to be using for fetching all
of this information so let me just go
ahead and type get
trending movies
so basically this is going to be a
function
normal function actually and it's also
going to have a completion callback
function let me just go ahead and type
that
name completion and it's going to be an
escaping function
we're just going to return a string for
now and that closure should be giving me
nothing
okay so um
for the ease of usage in the future i'm
also going to copy the base url from
here
so let me just go ahead and copy that
let's go back to xcode and create a new
constant over here
static
let base url going to paste in here
what we've copied before
and let's just go back to our
method
first of all i'm going to create the url
itself so um let's just type let
sorry guard let
url is going to be a url with a string
first thing that we need to paste in
here
um basically it's going to be our base
url
okay
and i believe there's a forward slash
over here let's just go back
to the um
to the developers dot the movie database
or website over here and let me just
copy
all
what we can see over here
so um yeah i'm going to copy all of that
and let me just paste that in here
and after the api key which is going to
be our first query for the database
website i'm going to paste in
my
api key
else return
so basically we have our url setup over
here so let's just do that and in this
course i'm not going to be using any
third uh parties for uh network layering
as alarm of fire and all that kind of
stuff we're going to be making all of
the
calls ourselves
so um let me just create a new task over
here
so let me just type url session
extras
shared dot
data task i'm
going to choose the one with the url
request over here
let me just create a new
url request with my url and for the
completion handler i'm going to be using
the data i don't need the response right
now and of course i need the error in
case we have any error calling the
functions
so
over here let me just go ahead and type
record let
data is equals to data
and also i'm going to make sure that the
error is equals to nil
i also should return of course
we're going to refactor this and add
more functionality but we just need to
um to get everything set up
i missed an else over here
okay so right now we have our data
okay so right now we just have our
data so let's just convert our data into
adjacent objects so that we can
serialize it and actually be able to use
it more easily so let me just go ahead
and type let results
equals to json serialization
dot json object with data
so i'm going to pass the data that we
had in here and also i'm going to allow
fragments
okay so let's just see what error that
we have basically this function throws
an error so
we must
execute that function inside the do
catch block
so let me just go here print error the
localized description and let me just
cut that and paste it over here
and since it throws an error let me just
add here the word keyword try actually
and over here i can
print the results
and before we end that we have created
the task and that task is by default is
created in the pause status so
we just need to
type task
dot resume
okay so our get trending movies function
is complete
now we are we just need to call that
function from our home controller so
that we can see the results over here
so over here let me just create a new
function
private find get trending movies
and basically this is where we're going
to uh call the functions so let me just
go ahead and
type api color share get trendy movies
and as you can see here
i don't need the uh return value right
now we just need to test
if everything is working fine
so uh yeah basically that's what we're
going to need
for now and
let me just go ahead to our view the
load method and let me just call that
function build and run and let's see the
results that we have
okay so as you can see here
our connection to the database has been
established successfully and we get our
results over here um as you can see here
uh we get lots of json objects and we
need to make uh start by making our
models so that we can serialize all of
these
so right now we have all of our
information over here in the console so
let's just go ahead and look at what all
of this information really are so as you
can see here
basically we have an array and that
array holds
a bunch of objects over here and each of
one each one of
these objects basically is just a title
that we're looking for so as you can see
here
each title has an attribute for the id
itself the media type as you can see
here it's a tv show um the name is money
heist and as you can see here the
original name is la casa de papel
we just need to uh to have an model so
that we can have the um the movies like
we have over here as you can see here we
have a movie that has the attribute name
of the id media type movie original
language english and all that kind of
stuff over here
it happens to be
venom so
let me just go ahead to our models
folder that we created earlier
and let's just create a new file over
here
i'm going to create a normal swift file
and let me type
movie so
in this file i'm going to create our
model that we're going to be using over
here so that we can um extract all of
the information over here that we need
so um basically we're going to create a
struct
and
let me just
call that um
trending
movies
response
so in this structure we're going to
create here an array
let's just call that results
and
be aware that these um it's a good
practice actually to match the names of
the attributes over here so the first
thing that we need to do is just we're
going to create this array so let's
results is going to be an array of
a single movie to be exact so that array
is multiple of this single item
and
you might see here that xcode is
complaining because it cannot find the
type movie in this scope and basically
this is what we're going to be doing
right now let's just create a new struct
let's call that movie
and
in here we're going to copy
basically um
all of the attributes that defines a
movie
so let's just go here as you can see
here that's the start of our object
basically that's the end so basically we
just need to copy that
to our um
to our file over here so that we can
create the model easily
let me just
facing here
okay so basically what we need basically
we need an id
maybe we're going to need a media type
original language original title so
let's just go ahead and get the
attributes that we need so um right here
we need the id of course and that's
going to be a type of hint
okay
let's media
type
it's going to be a string and i'm going
to make that optional so that if the um
if the movie database did not provide us
with the media type
we know for sure that
our app is not going to crash
let original
name
also going to be an optional string
let original
title
string
also going to be optional
but poster path and as you can see here
i'm getting all of these information
from here i'm just extracting what i'm
really um interested in so i can see
here poster path
poster
path and that's going to be an optional
string as well
left over
view
an optional string let vote count
and that is going to be an integer
let release
date also going to be an optional string
um
maybe i'm
interested in the vote average as well
so
let vote underscore average
and i believe that's going to be a
double
okay
so basically we have
created the um the model for the
response that we're getting over here
so um yeah so let's back go back to our
api caller over here
and we're going to delete this actually
all right so we just need to type json
decoder we just need an instance of that
decode and we're going to be um
providing the
model that we've just made over here
which is basically trending movies
response
so just pass in that
with the data
and um
okay so basically as you can see here um
there is an
error we get over here and that's
because we forgot basically to
conform to the codable
protocol and we just need to confirm in
here as well so basically the codable
protocol is just a type alias for the
encoder protocol and the decoder
protocol as well so um yeah we can just
remove the codable and just
since we're only using at the code
method but it's just
easier for us uh to um
not going to be prone to every errors in
the future so we just need to
conform to the codable protocol let me
just go back in here
and for now i'm going to um print the
results
let's build and run this
and let's see what do we have
okay so yeah we forgot actually to add
the try keyword over here let's build
and run this one more time and as you
can see here we've managed to
successfully get
the um the array of objects that we have
over here
okay so as you can see here we have the
trending movies response over there and
it's also a res uh it has the attribute
of results and inside that results array
we have all of our
um basically
um
data that we have
so um let's just access those there's
also dot results and since the results
is actually an array i'm going to
actually also access the first one and
as you can see here we have the id media
type original name um yeah basically we
have all the information that we need
over here so let me just for example
um print the um original name for the
first element that we get in this
and as you can see here yeah it's like
casa or papel
okay
so
so let's just go ahead and modify our
function a little bit
so basically we're just returning a
string so let me just go ahead over here
first
and create an enum
i'm going to call that api error
and that's going to conform to error i'm
going to create my own
error which is going to be failed to
get data
and over here i'm just going to
modify that
so basically we need to return the
results so basically like result
and as you can see here uh we're going
to be returning um
an array of movies so let me just go
ahead and type array movie and if not
we're just going to return an error
and over here i'm going to um add the
com call the completion
as you can see here um i'm just going to
provide here a result so
a success which is going to take an
array of movies so results dot results
let's just go back in here to our home
view controller
and as you can see here
right now i'm going to call that one
more time
api caller.share.gettrendingmovies
as you can see here actually i'm getting
results
so results
i'm going to switch on that results so
basically results
okay so in case of success i'm going to
get an array
of movies
different movies
and in the case of failure
i'm going to get an error over here
and let me just print the error
let's go back to our api caller as you
can see here if there's something wrong
that happened in the do block i can just
before brand the localized description i
can just delete that
completion
not failure and i can pass in my error
and i believe
um there's something wrong that needs to
be done over here and um
okay yeah that's the one we just need to
wrap that inside the parentheses over
here
and let's build and run that one more
time so that we make sure everything is
working and yes
we have everything is working right now
so that's it for this tutorial just to
recap really quick in this tutorial we
just managed to
establish our connection with the
database we fetched all the information
that we needed and also we serialized
those information back to a json object
and now we have the models uh the movie
model right here and now we're ready to
pass all of these information back to
our view controller let me just go to
our resources folder let me create a new
file it's going to be a normal switch
file i'm going to call that
extensions
and over here let me extend the um
the string data type
let me create a new function over here
it's going to be called capitalize first
letter
and that function is going to return a
string
and inside that function i just need to
type in for here return
self dot prefix i'm going to choose the
first letter
and i'm going to change that to an upper
case
and then i'm going to um add the self
dot lowercase
dot drop first so as you can see here
i'm only choosing the first letter
converting that to an uppercase and the
rest is going to be a lowercase and i'm
going to drop the first letter so that
we don't have multiple
um multiple letter as you can see here
so let me just go back to our home view
controller
and before i use that function i just
need to rearrange my array over here um
i noticed that in the real app um the
trending tv comes after the trending
movies so
let's just do that
and let me fix that by adding that comma
okay so let me just go down over here
uh where we set the text for each
section header uh instead of typing the
lower case i'm going to capitalize the
first letter and over here let me just
build and run this and let me see what
we got so far
okay so everything seems to be working
as i expected as you can see here the
first letter of each section is
capitalized so we utilize the concept of
extensions
so that we avoid duplicating code over
here and just adding
code that is not relevant to the
controller itself we just need to handle
that in its own extensions we don't need
to capitalize the first ladder over here
in our home view controller we don't
want to handle this over here in our
home controller it's not relevant you
know okay so in the last part we just
need to fix something regarding the api
that we've called to fetch the uh the
movies over here basically these movies
are going to be uh feed inside this
controller view and as you can see here
this i'm sorry this collection view and
this collection of you guys you might
guess it's all it should only um carry
the movies but let me just go ahead uh
for the api as you can see here we're
calling or fetching the trendings for
all kinds of data so instead of all i'm
going to change that to movie let me
just build and run that one more time
as you can see here we get the same
results
plus it is filtered we're only
retrieving the movies instead of having
both movies and tv at the same call okay
so we got the trending movies so right
now let me just go ahead and get the
trending tvs and basically it's going to
be
very similar to this so instead of using
all or movie we're just going to limit
that to use the tv itself
okay so let me just go ahead
and open the api caller yes we've
already opened that and let me just go
ahead let me just get more room over
here
let me create a new function
get
trending
tvs
okay we're going to have a completion
handler
and it's going to be escaping as well we
can just you know we can copy that from
over here
okay let me paste that over here where
instead of returning um
an array of tvs i'm sorry movies i'm
going to return an array of a tv
okay and let me see
the only error we get so far is that
because we don't have tv model yet but
just to get things started really
quickly i'm going to return the string
for now
and as you can see here xcode is no
longer complaining about this so let me
just go ahead and
initialize the url that we were going to
be working with so guard left
url is going to be url
string
i'm going to pass over here
um the
base url
okay
slash three slash trending
slash tv
slash
day okay we're going to be passing the
api key over here so basically it's the
same thing
um and you know what we can just copy
that from here just not to be prone to
area any errors
um
let me pass that
and instead of moving over here i'm
going to pass on tv
and they'll
return
so i'll just create a new task
url session
dot
shared
data task i'm going to do that with a
request url request
okay that takes a url which is basically
the url that we've just initialized up
here
and for the um the completion handler
we're gonna need the data i don't need
the url response i just need the error
and basically it's the same thing over
over here so guard let data is equals to
data and also i'm going to check
or make sure actually that the error
is equal to nil
and after
that i'm gonna do
do
let results equals try
um let me just go ahead and see jason
serialization dot
um let me just see here json object yes
data allow f fragments allowed
let me just go ahead and print the
results over here
and after that i'm gonna catch if
there's any errors so let me just go
ahead print error
dot localize description
what else do we need to do is just we're
gonna resume our task so that we can
see the result of that so let me just go
ahead and copy that get trending tvs let
me just go ahead to our home view
controller
and instead of calling the get trending
movies function going to um
let me see what we can do
change that name for
for a second
get
or fetch
data because this is just gonna be a
test function
let me just go over here
fetch
data
and we can um
comment that away because it's already
working we just need to
test the other one so api caller dot
share dot get trending tvs
and for the results
i'm not going to do anything right now
actually because we're already printing
that in the other api caller file so let
me just go ahead um and build and run
this and let me see if that is working
so um we have an error
let me see what do we have
okay
um
can i call a non-function type oh okay
just um an extra parentheses
so let me just build and run that and
let me see
and as you can see here we have the
response from the server and as you can
see here each and every one of them has
a media type of tv
so that is done
so we just need to create a new model
over here to handle the tv response
so um let me just do that so it's going
to be a new file over here
let me create a new swift file i'm gonna
call that tv
and let's have a look
so um as you can see here we have a tv
results which is basically an array that
holds
um
basically each and every
um object over here so let's just do
that structure
i'm going to make that with the same
basically with the same format over here
so instead of trending movie response
i'm going to call that
trending tv
response
and let's conform to the codable
protocol as well
and as you can see here that has a
results
um let me just
yeah and make sure to get the um
the spelling correctly that is going to
be an array of tv
and over here let me just create a new
structure i'm gonna call that tv
also i'm going to confirm the to the
codable protocol and let me see what do
i have for here
okay so um
i believe basically it's the same
um yeah i believe it's the same as movie
right here um i'm gonna copy that for
now
and to be honest it's not the best
practice over here because there is a
duplication of code
but uh i'm not sure
that
the um the database or the server itself
is going to have the same
um the same thing for the tvs and the
movies in the upcoming future so i'm
just you know because i'm not i don't
have any control over the server over
here so i'm just going to
um basically get that copied and i
believe
um that's okay let me just go ahead back
to my api caller
uh instead of that let me just type here
tv
and instead of using the normal json
serialization let me just go ahead and
convert that actually to
um the model itself that we've returned
so json
decoder
let me have an instance of that
um
what was it um i believe it's the same
one over here so yeah it's the code
and we're going to provide the um the
response that we're going to get so tv
or trending tv response dot self
okay
and the other one is going to be um
using the data that we have returned
here
let me just print the results and
crossing fingers i'm going to wish
that's going to work on the first try
and
yes it's working actually so yeah
basically this is going to be the
trending tv
uh we have the trending movies over here
let me just open um
here the simulator so let me just go
ahead and see okay so we need the
popular the upcoming movies and the top
rated as well and this is where we're
going to open tmdb
one more time
so let me just go ahead and we're going
to go through the api or the
documentation of the website itself so
let me just go ahead settings
api
developers.moviedatabase.org
and
yeah we can search over here so let's
say for example upcoming
and yeah there's an already method over
here
so let's see um i'm going to say try out
and basically this is the um the url
that we're going to use
so let me just go ahead and copy that
go back to xcode
api caller let me just paste that as a
comment over here and let me
make a new function
get
up
coming
and i'm going to call that upcoming
or let me see here basically yeah it's
going to be an upcoming movie so
upcoming movies
we're here we're going to use the same
um
signature of the function
okay so let me just paste that over here
we're going to return an array of movie
okay so let me just go ahead and create
the url for this as well so guard that
url is gonna be equals to url
and it's going to be from string
and let me just um paste that over here
so
let's just cut that i'm not going to
need that anymore
okay so
instead of having this
okay i'm going to remove that
let me just add the
base url from the constants so base url
movie upcoming api key we're just going
to um
substitute for that as well so constants
api key and i believe that says so else
return
i'm sorry let me just put that in the
curly braces return so we have our url
and now let's have the data task as well
so let
task is going to be a url session
dot shared
data task url request is going to take a
url which is basically done over here
and for the compilation handler as well
same stuff and as you can see here just
a type of pattern it's not that hard to
get um
comfortable with that
so um let's just guard let data is
equals to data and over here we just
want to make sure that the error as well
is equals to nil
okay
let me just do i do catch block print
error
dot localize description and over here
let me just select results
it's going to be equal to try
json um
let's just go ahead for here and type
json decoder decode and i'm going to
return
the um trending movies i believe
so um
[Music]
let me just try if that works
because i believe it's going to be the
same model
we're going to use that from data
and over here let me just print
results
and let me just go ahead to my home view
controller
um this works as well so let me just
comment that
for now
okay
and over here let me just type api
caller.share.
get upcoming movies for the result right
now i just don't need it
and let me just build and run let me see
here if there is any response for the
upcoming movies
okay
i'm not seeing anything right now
so yeah and that's because we've created
the task and we forgot to
change that to resume so
task.resume let me just build and run
c
okay so yeah we actually can use the
same model because it's not changed it's
the same across all the um the movies
that's being retrieved from the database
as you can see here
so we have the trending movies
let me just open that one more time so
we have the trending movies trending tvs
upcoming movies top rated and popular so
let me just go ahead and do the same
thing over here so
popular get popular
um
okay
so it's going to be basically the same
so we're just going to do that really
quick
and let's just go ahead one more time
over here
get upcoming movies is working fine let
me just test
the other one api caller share dot
get popular
and we don't need to return anything
right now
okay
so let's build and run
and let me see and before i do that i
already again forgot to
resume the task
and let me just build and run and let me
see
okay so um yeah i'm sorry guard let's
guard
let yeah that's going to work
and we forgot to add the try
keyword over here
and yeah everything is working fine
right now so basically we just need to
set up one last
um
one last api call which is basically the
top rated so let me just go ahead and do
that really quick
and
yeah as you can see everything is set up
right now
so basically that's it for this tutorial
we've completed our api calls and in the
next tutorial we're going to extract the
um the information that we just need
over here and start adding uh pictures
and posters and have something really
working on our app
okay so before we move ahead and use the
information that we got from the
database um i just gave it a thought and
i thought this is just the exact same
model for both the tv and the movie so
we don't need to um to have this
duplicated over here so we can just go
ahead and delete the tv model
move to trash
and that i'm going to rename that to
maybe um trending title response
and that's going to hold an array of
titles
and over here i just need to change that
to title as well
okay
and we can rename the file if you want
to
um
let me just go ahead
and rename that so title
all right and just to fix the error that
xcode is going to throw at us in the api
caller
we're going to change all of this from
movie to title
and over here
trending title response
okay
and the tv as well it's going to be a
title
basically um
it's just removing the old
name passing the new one it's really
simple
okay
just a second please
i believe that's the last one for the
top rated
and we can just build and run to see
that if everything is working
and indeed yes everything is
working and um yeah one last thing that
we need to do um we have uh made the um
the enumerator or basically our enum for
the api error over here and we haven't
used that already so
instead of passing a normal error i'm
just going to pass my api error and fail
to get data
i'm going to copy that actually and
instead of just printing the error i'm
going to pass in a failure
so that we can handle that from our home
view controller
so instead of each um print statement
inside the
catch block we can
um just remove that and instead add the
completion with failure api fill it to
get the data
okay
so what we need to do now is just go
ahead to the views
folder and create a new file
this is going to be a coco touch class
we're going to um
create a new collection view cell let me
just call that title collection view
cell and that is going to be the cell
that is responsible for
um handling everything inside the
collection view instead of the default
uh collection view set that we get with
the collection view
so let me just go ahead and press next
create
um
yeah it's just an old
um
an old file you're not going to see that
so right in here i'm just going to type
static select identifier
and let me just copy the name of the
class over here
and we're just going to need to
initialize that with the
normal
um
frame and over here let me pass also the
required initializer so that we avoid
um
adding and errors
and yes everything is set up regarding
the cell right now the only thing that
we need is that we just need an image
view so that we can pass the poster in
it so
right over here let me just try private
let's poster image view
and that is going to be a type ui image
view let me just use the anonymous
closure pattern
select image view is going to be ui
image queue
return image
review and over here we just need to
say image view dot content mode
um scale aspect fill
okay
so regardless the size or the aspect
ratio of the poster that we get we make
sure that we fill the entire cell that
we have here in the collection view and
over here i just need to um add this so
content view don't add some view poster
image view and i'm not going to use
actually the old layout for this it's
just
simple as
laying the frame of the view as the
whole or the entirety of the content
view so let me just go ahead and say
layout sub views
super dot layout sub views make sure to
include
make sure to include that line
and also add um poster image view the
frames gonna be equal content you don't
bounce
okay
and
that's it regarding the um the
collection
view cell um
yeah one more thing that we need to add
actually
a third-party library that is going to
help us cache
the retrieved poster or the image that
we get from the internet so let me just
go ahead and open safari and let me
introduce you to another third-party um
package that we're going to use in our
project which is basically
swift sd web image
and you can go over here into the github
page uh we're going to use the swift
package manager so
as you can see here the package.swift
file is included so that means that we
can use that without coco touch
so let me just go ahead and
copy
the uh the link for this github
repository let me just go ahead to xcode
file
add packages
and as you can see here since i've added
this package already it
it is cached inside the swift package
manager but for your case you're just
going to need to paste that over here
and as you can see here
um it got you the sd web image already
so you can tap add package
and xcode is just going to fetch the
required code from the github repository
is just not going to take much time as
you can see here
all right so um
xcode finished getting the uh the code
from the github repositories so just one
thing that we need to do before adding
the package we just need to make sure
that we check
both the sd web image and the sd web
image map kit
and then add that package
and as you can see here inside the
targets you see the uh netflix clone um
sd web image so that means that those
packages are targeted for our uh project
over here
so let me just go back to my title
collection view cell
let me import
the sd loop image
and inside here
um
each time we dq a cell in our collection
view so we just need to have an update
function so that we can update the
poster for each cell with the models
that we have in the
home view controller
so let me just go ahead and define a
public function
this time so public function
configure
web
model
and
for now we're just gonna pass a string
for now
all right so basically this model string
this model of data type string for now
is just going to hold
the url for the poster that we're
looking for so basically we're just
gonna have to type poster
dot
sd
set image
and we're going to set that image with a
url
so let me just go ahead and find my url
it's going to be equal to url
from string
let me for now pass the model
okay i believe this is going to be a
guard url
else return
because it's just going to
give us an optional url and over here
i'm going to pass the url and for the
completion i just need to pass nil
okay so we are set up over here
so let me just go back to my home view
controller
and in this
part of uh tutorial we're going to be
viewing the view models right now
because we don't actually need to pass
the entirety of the um the title model
we just need
maybe the uh the poster path over here
we don't need the id the media type or
anything from here right now let me just
go ahead back to my home view controller
and let me see here the apis that we
have
so as you can see here we have five api
calls the last one is the get upgraded
in the upcoming movies and basically
those are the api calls that we're going
to be using to fetch the data from the
database to feed the table view cells
that we have
okay so basically this is not how we're
going to be fetching actually the data
from the api we want every single
section to handle its own calls so let
me just go ahead and delete the fetch
api data from here
and also let me delete the call for the
method and one last time i just want to
go to the api caller and i want to make
sure that i'm passing the results back
uh instead of just printing them so let
me just copy the completion handler over
here and let me pass this in every
single api call
so we're done with the api caller right
now so let me just go back to my home
view controller let me just go on the
top of the um the home view controller
class and let me define a new in them
i'm going to call that sections and that
is going to have a real value type of
int
i'm going to define my cases over here
so basically trending movies and that's
going to be equal to 0
case trending tv that's going to be
equal to one
basically
um i believe it was the uh popular
and that's going to be equal to
case
upcoming
three and the last one is going to be
top rated
and that is going to be equal to four so
basically those are the four
cases or the four sections that we're
going to have over here
okay so um
okay so since we've um created um a
title collection over here that is our
um
cell let me just go back to the um
to the collection view actually that is
going to be handling each cell over here
and instead of just registering a ui
collectionview.self over here i just
need to delete that
and instead i'm going to pass in the
title collection view cell that i i have
created actually
instead of the identifier i can just
access this by the name
of the class the identifier so right now
i have the title collection view cell
over here
all right
and instead of just dequeuing um a
normal cell let me just delete that and
make that from the beginning so guard
let cell's going to be equal to
collection view cell
dot dq with reusable identifier which is
basically title collection view cell dot
identifier
and over here i'm just going to pass the
index pass
as
title collection view cell else we're
just gonna return a normal collection
view cell
over here
and basically i'm going to return the
cell
and as you can see here basically we
have access to the configure method that
we made earlier
okay
so
um basically um
something else that we need to do here
we're just gonna have to um initialize a
private
var titles
that is going to be an array that is
going to hold our titles and i'm going
to initialize that array actually to be
an empty array for now
all right
okay so and then
i'm going to make a new
configure
with function over here just to uh feed
the titles that we get for each section
in this array so let me just go here
type configure
web
titles
and that is going to be an array of
title
right and inside that we're just going
to reference the titles array that we
have and basically pass in the titles
that we get for each section
all right so
let me just go back to my home view
controller over here let me just scroll
down
um yes this is the one so basically
right now we have an access to a new
function
which is basically the titles and we are
going to pass in the um
the titles that we get over here but
we're just going to switch first
on this section
so let me just type switch
index path
dot section
and right here we're going to handle the
cases for each section so let me just
type the cases that we have
case
sections
dot
trending movies
case sections dot trending tv
case sections
popular
case sections
dot
upcoming and the last one sec case
sections
dot top rated
so basically those are the four cases
that we're going to handle so in each
case over here i just need to um
oh basically it's not just trending
movies so basically we need the role
value which of which we have assigned
when we uh actually um initialize our
enumerator over there so
row value
dot row value
value over here
and here as well so basically let's just
handle the first case that we have
so for the first case that we have we
just need to make the api call so api
color shared get trending movies and i
just need the result over here
and on the result as well i'm going to
switch one more time so switch
result
case
success i'm just going to receive the
titles
and over here i just wanna
pass the results that we have to myself
so i configure cells and that configure
method expects to receive an array of
titles so basically
array over here
and over here i'm just going to handle
the other case which is basically going
to be the failure
so let error
and over here for now i'm just going to
print the error localized description
all right
so basically we have uh handled the
first one
so let me handle the second one over
here
okay api caller.share.com
result
okay
just a second
i'm going to switch one more time on the
result
case success
let titles
i'm just going to pass it
with the confederate method
all right
any other case is going to be failure
same thing ever
and for now i'm going to print the error
right
and the other one is going to be the
same api color share dot
popular
and the result
i'm going to switch on the result for
the get popular
case success
i'm going to receive the titles
i'm going to pass the titles over here
any other case
i believe you
know
right now what we're going to be doing
let error
okay print the error localized
description
we have two more to go
so
let's just api caller shared
in the upcoming i'm going to get the
result
i'm going to switch on the result as you
can see here
okay so case
success like titles
i'm going to pass that to with the
configure method as well
case failure
that error
all right so just print the error
and one last
time we're going to do that for the top
rated
so let me just go ahead and
okay api caller.share.operated
i'm going to
receive a result let me switch on the
result one last time
okay success
select titles
i'm going to pass the titles
for the cell
all
right one more to go
case failure that error
and let me just print the error over
here
all right
and we just need to um
[Music]
to see what we have here basically we
have an error that xcode is throwing at
us because the switch
uh block must be an exhaustive so let me
just go ahead and fix that real quick
all right and let me see over here so
basically it adds a default uh case um
so let me just go ahead and just return
what um i believe is going to be a table
view cell
so yeah so return
ui table view cell
and right now we can just build and let
me see if we get any error build
succeeded so as you can see here it's
really really clean way look at that
um each section is handling its own
calls
all right
so um let me just go ahead
and open the configure method over here
which is basically for the collection
table view uh cell and as you can see
here uh we are going to um set the
titles
for the um for the collection view cell
array over here let me just go back or
scroll down to the collection view cell
that's going to handle each poster for
each movie and i'm going to return
actually the titles.count
all right
so um instead of just passing the empty
string over here i'm going to pass the
titles
i'm going to
say index path the row as you can see
here basically i have access to each and
every single title over here so before
now let me just add the poster path over
here
and let me just open the configure
method over here one more time and
instead of um
passing the url over here i just need to
see the url first so
let me just print
the model that we have over here
so um let me just build and run this and
let me see what we get
okay we have an error
and that is going to be um yeah that is
an optional string for now
so um let me just guard let
right poster
or let me just say um model
is going to be equal to titles
index
path
dot row
the poster path which is basically the
um the reason i'm having an error over
here because the poster path if you
remember is just an
optional string
all right so
let me just type else
and over here i'm going just to return
ui collection view cell for now just to
remove the error
and over here instead of passing this
i'm just going to pass in the model
so before i build and run this i just
need first to type this so dispatch q
dot main
dot async and i'm going to explain what
i'm doing right now in just a second so
let me just my first week self
in and inside this function i'm going to
reference my collection view
self.collectionview.reloaddata
so basically
um we have retrieved the titles um in
earlier uh within the uh the home view
controller and then we updated the title
array that we have over here but since
that array has been updated in an async
function we need to reload the data for
the collection view inside the main
thread and this is why i'm typing here
dispatchqueue.main.async
so let me just build and run this and
let me see what we have
all right so basically as you can see
here since the trending movies is the
only
row on the screen right now so basically
i have um
i have gotten like one two maybe those
are seven uh images from the data and as
i scroll here as you can see i'm
actually retrieving more images and when
i'm scrolling over here for each section
as well as you can see here basically we
are getting the images for each section
and each title inside each section as
you can see over here
so let me just go really quick to
the movie database api
let me just open the uh developers
web page over here
it's really easy so let me just type
image
let me say over here images and as you
can see here there's a pattern so
basically this
is the result that we have retrieved
from the uh data api so basically we
just need to copy the entire thing over
here and basically we are just going to
feed the data that we've got instead of
the um the hard coded value over here
so i just go back to my title view
controller
and here let me just create a new url so
guard let urls come to via url with a
string and that url is basically going
to be
this and i'm going to pass in the model
that i have
over here
and else i'm just going to return so
basically once we have the api ready we
can use that to set the um the image url
that we have over here and for the
completion let me just type nil and let
me build and run this
so as you can see here basically we have
all the image for each title and i
believe this is the moment that you guys
have been waiting for since the
beginning of this series as you can see
here for each section i have the
trending movies as you can see here it's
actually updated and as you can see here
spider-man uh basically this is the
movie that has been trending for like a
week over now um trending tvs as you can
see here money highs the witcher and all
that kind of stuff so
let's go to the upcoming view controller
over here and first thing that we need
to do is just to set the title so let me
just type title i'm going to send that
to upcoming
and over here i'm just going to
um type navigation controller navigation
bar prefers large titles and i'm going
to send that to
true
navigation controller dot navigation
item dot large title display mode and
i'm going to set that to always as well
so right now let me just create a new
table i'm going to call that
upcoming table so privately
upcoming table let me just type that
correctly
that's going to be a ui table view i'm
going to set that with the anonymous
closure we use that so many times at
this point in this year so let me just
type table i'm going to say
ui table view i'm going to register a
normal cell for now
so register
ui table view cell
itself i'm going to set the identifier
to be um cell
and don't forget to return that table
i'm going to add that table to my view
so
you add some view
upcoming table i'm going to set the
delegate for the uh for the table view
up here as well so upcoming table
delegate is going to be equal to self
upcoming data source is going to be
called itself as well
i'm going to extend
the controller so extension
upcoming view controller i'm going to
set that ui table view delegate and the
upcoming
for the data source as well so ui table
view data source
i'm going to implement the two functions
over here so basically return 10 for now
and for this i'm going to return the
delegate function which is the cell for
row so
let's just create a new cell so let's
sell it's going to be able to table view
i'm not that one so table view
dot dq with identifier and four so let
me just type here
cell
index
for now i'm just
going to
say text label the text i'm going to
send that
for test um right now and let me just go
ahead and return myself
so that should be working so right now
um i'm going to hit run and let me see
what i guess so far
okay so as you can see here we have the
home view controller nothing have has
changed let me just go to the coming
soon and as you can see here i have my
upcoming title and when i scroll um
there's nothing to be scrolled at right
now because we haven't played the table
yet so let me just go ahead and
implement the function so
did lay some view i'm going to
say super the view that layout some view
upcoming table
let me just
say that
upcoming table.frame that is going to be
equals to view.bounce
let me hit one one more time
all right
so as you can see here uh we have the
title we have our tail
cells ready so
right now let me just reuse the function
that we've used earlier in the upcoming
or i'm sorry in the home view controller
so let me just create a new function
over here so private func
fetch up coming
and i'm going to implement that function
so um i'm going to call the api caller
the shared get upcoming movies and i'm
going to switch on the results
so switch result and i'm going to type
in here
case success
let me just retrieve those titles
okay
and in here
i'm going to assign that to a local
variable that i'm going to
call titles as well so let me just go up
in here
private
var
titles
that is going to be an array of title
i'm going to initialize that array
so that is going to be empty for now
all right and over here just to avoid
any memory leaks so i'm just going to
type weak self
and over here i'm just going to
reference that back so basically self
dot
titles that is going to be titles
and over here as well i'm just going to
reload the data so self dot upcoming
table dot reload data and i'm just going
to put that inside an async
function so that we make sure that it's
going to be executed on the main thread
so let me just type this
patchqueue.main.async and i'm going to
add that
line of code in here so that we don't
get any errors let me just go back in
here at the number of rows i'm going
just to return titles.count
and over here i'm just going to
set that one more time over here let me
just type
titles
um let me just see here yeah titles okay
i'm going to
access the index path of row and as you
can see here
um
what do we have okay
something's wrong
oh i'm sorry this is um
we just misspelled the word so
we have it right now so titles
let me just
fix that that's well so
titles
and let me just go ahead one more time
and as you can see here we have the
original name and since this is an
optional we can say
default value
which is basically going to be also
titles index path row and i'm going just
going to as access the original title
and if neither of those available i'm
just going so i'm going to assign that
to unknown and let's hope that we don't
actually reach to that point let me fix
the error up here because i have a
misspelled word
so return titles dot count and i believe
everything is done right here oh we have
to
uh basically
um
handle the other case which is going to
be the failure let me just retrieve the
error over here
it's really easy tutorial
to be honest i'm going to just print the
error not localized description
all right build and run and let me see
what do i get so far
and as you can see here i get nothing y
because actually we have created the
function but we forgot to call the
function itself so let me just paste in
that here let me call the function
and let me hit build and run and let me
see what do i get so far
all right so basically i have a list
over here um
it has
all the names for each title and
basically the thing that we need to do
right now is just we need to create a
custom cell so that we preview the title
we want to preview the play
button and also we wanted to preview the
poster for the cell
so um let me just go back to my views
let me just create a new file that is
going to be a coco touch class
um i'm going to create
actually a ui table
view cell
um let me call that maybe title
table view cell
all right
and for the language i'm just going to
make sure that it's going to be created
with swift
all right so let me create this
so right now i have an empty cell so let
me just um type the static
static let
identifier and that is going to be the
name of the class that we have so title
table view cell let me just paste in
that in here let me initialize that
um with the normal
instructor um constructor i'm sorry so
i'm going to pass the style
and the reusable identifier as well
and over here i'm just going to um add
the other
required initializer i'm going to say
fail error and over here i'm just going
to implement the views that i going to
create so the first thing i'm going to
do is just going to
have a ui image so that it holds the
poster for the title that we retrieved
from the server so let me just type
private
let
title poster
ui image view
ui image view which is going to be the
type i'm going
to use the same anonymous closure so let
image
view there's going to be an image view
all right so imageview.content
mode i'm going to set that to
um
maybe um
yeah scale aspect fit
image view
um
yeah i'm going to return the image view
for now
okay um basically we need to add this
for the cells so let me type content
um
view dot add some view i'm going to add
the title poster
ui image view all right
next thing that we need is just a label
that it's going to hold the title name
so let me just type private let
title label
um not titles it's only title label
and that is going to be a type of ui
label
all right so let label it's going to be
equal to ui label i'm going to um
return the label for now
and if we need to do anything we're
going to
add that
later so let me just
um yeah i'm going to basically use the
content auto layout so i'm going to
activate that so label dot
um translates auto resizing masking into
constraints i'm going to set that to
false
i'm going to use that as well with the
image view so instead of a label i'm
going to type image view
i'm going to add
the label to my content view as well so
content view dot add some view um type
the label
um what do i need um next um i believe
is it's going to be a button
so let me just type in here
private let
play title button
this is going to be a ui button i'm
going to initialize that so that button
is going to be ui to ui button
i'm going to return that button as well
but i'm going to activate the auto
layout attribute so basically button dot
translate auto resizing mask
it's false
um i'm going to run that or call that to
be exact and also i'm going to
add that to my content view add some
view i'm going to add my button over
here
um all right so basically make a new
function over here i'm going to call
that apply constraints
all right
so let me just go ahead and create the
function so private fund create
constraints
and the first constraint that i'm going
to have is basically um the poster
uh and the title label and also the
button so let me just type in here let's
i'm going to copy the name of this
variable over here
i'm going to add constraints as well so
constraints that's going to be an array
let me copy that one paste that one more
time so basically i'm going to
constrain the leading anchor
um to be constrained with the content
view dot leading anchor as well
i'm going to
set the top
anchor to be constrained with the
um i believe it's going to be with the
content view as well which is going to
be the top anchor i'm just going to add
some margin
at top
maybe it's going to be 15 points
all right um
titles um poster image view dot bottom
anchor the constrain
also to the content view dot bottom
anchor i'm just going to
reverse that to be negative 15.
and for the width so let me just
choose maybe 100 point
and over here i'm just going to activate
this
constraints
okay
and also i'm going to create a create
i'm sorry i forgot the separator over
here i'm just going to create a
public function
i'm going to call that
configure
with
model
i'm just going to
pass the view model over here that was
going there's going actually to hold the
poster the label
and that's it i guess so basically let's
type title
i'm sorry title
view model we don't have this yet
um so basically um let's just
choose the imageview that we have in sd
set image with the url
and over here i'm just going to add this
url so let
url i'm sorry guardlet
or that url is going to be a url
i'm going to call that with a string
over here so basically i'm going to pass
model
dot poster
url
all right so else return
okay and i'm going to pass the url over
here for the completion i'm going to
pass nil and what else do we need to do
basically we just need to set the title
as well so basically title label dot
text that is going to be our from our
model
um dot um
tile
name okay
um i'm just going to change the pascal
this okay so title name
let me just go to my view model over
here
let me create a new file this is going
to be a swift file
and let me just type title
view model
all right that is going to be a
structure
title
view model
let me just type let
title name
that's going to be a string
and let
poster
url that's going to be a string as
well all right so um i guess that's it
for now so let me just
make sure that we have everything set up
over here the poster
path is a string as well so we can
go back to
my title
table view this
that this error is going to go away
right now so basically we have our um
sales setup let's just complete adding
the constraints
so let um i'm going to copy that because
it's
um it's title label it's a good practice
actually to name to have a consistent
naming convention so title label
um constrains
all right
that's going to be an equal to an array
of constraints so basically title label
dot leading anchor the constraints i'm
going to add that next to the poster so
basically
poster
title poster image view the trailing
anchor
um and that is going to be
next to the poster by maybe 20
points all right so title label
dot um
center y
i'm going to constrain that with the
cell itself
so basically
content view dot center y anchor
i believe that's it for the um
for the constraints for the labels so
let me just activate this constraints as
well so ns layout
activate
title label constraints
and
okay so let me just go back to my
upcoming view controller instead of just
registering a normal cell let me just
type title
table view cell i'm going to access the
identifier so title table view
cell.identifier
and over here i'm just going to dequeue
this cell
so let me just type guard
let's cell is going to be able to table
view the tq
for the identifier title table view
cell.identifier for the index path
as title table view cell else i'm going
just to
return a normal cell for now
ui table view cell
all right and over here i'm just going
to access that so cell as you can see
here we have the um
the configure the configure
expects to have a title view model so
let me just give that to the um to the
function so it expects the title name
and the title poster and we can easily
access that using the titles array that
we have
index path the row and over here you can
see um basically we can actually define
that over here so title is going to be
um
titles dot index path dot row
and over here i'm just going to add the
title
dot
um original title maybe if it's not
there so title dot original name
and for the poster url i'm just going to
access the title as well and i believe
it's here under the path
dot
i'm sorry the poster path
and actually i'm going to return that
cell
and before i hit run i just discovered
that we are only
adding the um
the path after the the url so i'm going
to copy that from the view that we made
earlier at the home view controller
but that
yeah that needs to be unwrapped first
um but for now we can just um
add or fix that with the normal over
here so basically we just need to add
the default value as well so unknown
title name so let me just go back to my
collection table view cell i believe
um basically let me just yeah basically
i'm going to copy
that um line over here
right and let me just go back to my
title table let me just go
to the um to the line that i'm going to
set the url
so um let me just paste that in here
um copy this model the poster url
instead i'm going to add this
model.poster url let me just delete that
i believe we have every everything set
up over here let me just
hit run and let me see what do i get
i believe that there is an error let me
just see
what is the error over here uh yeah
basically we just need to add a default
value which is going to be an empty
string
let me type build and run
coming soon
and yeah there's something wrong with
the
with the cell
but clearly we see here
the um the title the poster and
basically we just need to
fix the height of the row um so let me
just type in here um
row height or
height for row let's just return
maybe um 90. let me just build and run
one more time let me see what do i get
coming soon
all right so we're going we're getting
somewhere so i believe i'm just going to
modify or just play around with the
numbers over here
so um
yeah i believe that is okay
um
all right so we can actually increase
that maybe to 140.
let me see what do i get at the end so
let me just go back in here um yeah it's
getting
better and better you can just play
around with this let me just add the
button over here um i've made the button
i believe so let me just
make sure that i have the cell over here
so title table
view cell i have the button
um
let me just go and set the image
and this is going to be a system image i
believe it's going to be play the circle
play the circle
and this is going to be for normal right
now
adding this so let me just add the
constraints for that as well so let me
just copy the name
let me just over here create new
constraints for that button
okay
and i'm going to set the um
the trailing anchor to be exact so the
trailing anchor is going to be set from
the constraint actually with the
training anchor of the sale itself so
i'm just content view dot railing anchor
and i'm going to add a constant which is
going to be
minus
20.
i'm going to add
the constraints to fix it at the middle
of the cell as well so
center y anchor is going to be
constrained with the content view the
center y anchor as well i'm just going
to activate this so activate play title
button
um constraints so let me just hit build
and run and let me see
um all right we are go we're getting
much closer to the um to the finished
product
um let me just go back in here let me
just button the tint color that is going
to be white
and
actually i'm going to change the size of
the image so let me just get the image
over here so let me just copy that all
right so i have the image
and over here i'm just going to say
um with configuration
ui image
okay dot symbol configuration i believe
um yeah and over here i can just
change the point size maybe um 40
and let me pass the image over here
let me build and run and let me see what
do i get
okay um yeah basically that's it so i'm
just going to
play around with the um with the size of
the button as well over here so
um
yeah basically that's it just go to the
poster and type image view dot clips to
the bounds and set that to true and that
will prevent each poster from
overflowing the container and also we
can just decrease the padding just a
little bit maybe to 10 instead of 15
and then let me test that to see if that
is working
and
yes everything is fixed right now you
can see here that each poster has like
10 points up and bottom so basically
everything is fixed regarding the
upcoming tab and now let's just go ahead
and move to the top search so basically
the top search is going to have the same
functionality
that the upcoming tab has so first of
all let me just copy those three lines
over here
all right and let me paste that over
here and we can just
change that to search let me hit build
and run to see if it's working
and as you can see here
all right so
the next thing that we need to do right
now is just we want to have a table view
so that we can display
maybe a discover tab for the user before
um before the user enters a query to
search for so maybe he want to discover
what is trending right now uh or what he
might be interested at so let me just go
ahead and
define my table um basically we can copy
the same table over here i just wanted
to make this really quick
so let's just copy that
go back in here
and let's just paste that maybe i'm
gonna call that this cover
table
all right and that is going to have the
same
title uh table view cell which is
basically why i've made it like a
generic one so that we can reuse it in
so many places as you can see here once
in the upcoming tab and the the other in
the search review
all right so over here
um let me just clear that space um and
let me add that as a sub view so
discover table
and
over here i'm going to set the layout
so
lay out so view that layouts of views
super view the layouts of views and i'm
going to give that a frame
with the bounce of the view itself so
view the bounce
right and also over here just make sure
to you know set the delegate and the
data source for the table view to be
that controller so that we can implement
all the functions that we're gonna use
to
pass the data and also pass the number
of rows so
discovertable.delegate
is going to be equal to self
discover table the data source also
going to be equal to self
all right let's just go down there
extension
search view controller and let me type
ui
table view
um data source
ui table view delegate
all right just a second ui table
right
so first thing that we need to implement
is the number of rows
for now let me just return 10
and sell for row also
maybe i'm gonna be returning a cell
right now so
we have the sale so let's just do guard
let's sell going to be equal to table
view
dq cell with identifier um i believe
it's title
table view cell dot identifier
for index path
as title table view cell and else we're
going to return
a normal ui to table view cell
all right and over here let me just
return the cell for now because actually
we don't have data yet okay so let me
just go really quick to um the movie
database
um
maybe we can find
the method that we're looking for
i'm gonna maybe we can find the method
that we're looking for i believe it's
called discover
um so let me just go to the website and
type in here
maybe discover yeah movie discover over
here and we can just scroll down until
we see
um try it out you can just add
the uh
the attributes that you want
to search the or to query the database
with
let's say for example
that you're looking for specific region
uh specific language and also you can
just put your api key over here and test
that out and it's gonna give you the
results
so basically let me just copy that out
all right
and let me go back to my api caller
we're going to add a new function over
here all right so let me just
type func
get
this
movies
all right
and let me just copy that
signature
over here
just i'm gonna make that really quick
and also basically we're gonna implement
the same functionality over here so let
me just
do that
let's just copy that
um basically we just need to
write so let me just go ahead and paste
the url over here
all right so um basically we're gonna
have the same constant base url
and we want to pass our api key instead
of
the top rated i'm just going to add the
same stuff over here
so let me just go ahead and delete that
and make sure that i have the same
constant base url all right so i'm going
to copy all that and paste that in here
just a second
all right so let me just delete that i
don't need it anymore
and instead of the api key over here i
can just
pass the one i have
so let me just do that constants dot
api key
and as you can see here
everything's set up we can use the uh
discover movies function
all right
it looks clean
all right so let me just go back to my
upcoming i'm sorry it's the the search
view controller and let me just define a
new variable over here so private
var
titles
and we just
cop we can just copy that
from here
all right
and then we can um use the same function
so
fetch
discover movies
let's just
define that function over here so
private func
i'm going to basically um
call the api caller
the shared dot get
discover movies
and for the result i'm going to switch
on that
switch result
all right switch result
case success
let me get those titles
and let me assign those titles over here
to the titles array that we have
so um
titles
um
okay
it's okay we're gonna do this
we self
so self the titles is gonna be able to
titles
and over here we just need to
set that on the main thread as well so
let me just do dispatch queue.main.async
and over here i'm just going to
reference my table
so discover table dot reload data
and over here i'm just going to handle
the other case really quick so failure
select error is going to be
just simple
print statement
all right so now we have everything set
up over here
and let me just go ahead and use that
um
variable that we made and get the count
for it
so that we have the number of rows that
we're going to be using
we can also
set the cell the configure i believe we
have that
the title um
the title view model we're going to
define that over here so let
model
is going to be equal to title view model
and the title name
is going to be um
alright so
we can pass that in here
and here let me just get the title that
title
it's going to be equal to
titles
right
index path
the row
and now we have the title so basically
title
dot
maybe the title name
if that is not available let me just
pass in here the title dot the original
name again no no
um
the title original title yes
and if it's not available let me just
pass
unknown
name
and over here let me just pass in the
poster path
all right so everything's set up over
here
and
yeah let me just add um
and default
empty string over here because that is
going to be an optional and before we
hit build and run um let me just fix
something really quick before we get the
same error that we had before with the
um with this with the upcoming view
controller basically which is the height
for row
and let's just return the same number
that we returned at the upcoming view
controller which is 140
so let me just return 140 let me just
hit build and run and let me see the
results that we get so far
all right so the home controller working
fine
the upcoming tab is also working fine
and the search tab is also working fine
and first of all i'm just going to
create a new file this is going to be a
new view controller of type coco touch
class and let me call that search
results and basically that is going to
be the controller
responsible for viewing the data that
we're going to retrieve from the
database server
once we completed our query so let me
just um
delete all of that we're not going to
need that and also i'm just going to
give that a new background color so that
we can provide that is working so let me
just choose maybe system green and as
you can see here basically uh we are
having multiple files so i just wanted
to rearrange my file hierarchy so let me
just go ahead and create a new group i'm
going to call that core and i'm just
going to add the home view controller
upcoming view controller the search view
and the main tab bar as well as the
downloads view controller inside that
core all right i'm going to create also
a new group
so let me just call that maybe general
and inside that i'm just going to add
the new file that i've just created over
here basically the search results view
controller all right
so um let me just go back to core
search view controller and over here i'm
just going to start working on my
search bar so let me just type private
let
search
controller that is going to be of a type
ui search controller with the same
method which is basically the anonymous
closure i'm just going to create a new
um controller over here so basically ui
search controller
and as you can see here we can specify
the search result controller basically
let's just type in here search
results view controller and i'm just
going to get that and give that actually
a new instance
let me just
go ahead and type controller
basically search bar
dot placeholder and here we can specify
any message that we want to prompt the
user so let me just type something like
search
for a movie
or a tv
show
all right um maybe we can change that to
be a capital
all right and also i'm just going to add
this um line over here so controller the
search bar
search bar style and i'm just going to
choose minimal and as you can see here
basically you can just read what is the
minimal so basically the search bar has
no background whatsoever and the search
field is translucent so i'm just going
to choose that and i'm going to return
the controller over here let me just go
back to my view did load and i'm just
going to add that to my view so
basically let me just type navigation
item
dot search controller and i'm just going
to pass that search controller that
we've just made
all right build and run and let me see
what we get so far so um as you can see
here we can go to the top search and
basically you can see here the search
bar is ready um search for a movie or a
tv show basically this is the
placeholder that we specified earlier
and as you can see here once i begin my
scrolling it basically fades out or as
you can see here this effect is giving
you by default by apple thanks apple uh
basically apple is taking so much work
out of our shoulders so basically once i
start typing in here as you can see here
the search controller is actually
responsible for showing me the search
results view controller that we have
made in here and basically this is going
to be uh where we add our table view and
our collections view for basically
viewing the results that were fetching
from the database and once i hit
backspace or delete and as you can see
here it by default disappears so um
basically we're going to start working
with the search view or the search
results you can show over here but first
i just need to change that color
so let me just go back in here and type
navigation controller dot nav bar dot
thing color and i'm just going to set
that by default to white let me build
and run this and let me see if that is
working
so um yes as you can see here the cancel
button is just white right now so we
have consistency around our application
so let's go back to the search results
view controller and over here i'm just
going to initialize basically a new
collection view so let me just type
private let
search
results
collection view
that is going to be a ui collection view
let me initialize that so basically let
collection
view
is going to be equal to ui collection
view
and i'm just going to initialize that
with the zero frame for now and
regarding the layout let's just pass in
here layout so let me just go up in here
let me create that layout so private
light or basically just let
layout is going to be ui collection view
flow layout
all right so layout the item size
maybe we can give that a size of cg size
of um maybe like something like
a hundred or um 200 maybe and now let me
just register a new cell over here so
basically let's just try to reuse the
title collection view cell that we have
in here so basically let me type the
title
um collection view cell dot cell all
right for the identifier so basically
let's just access that one more time and
basically i can find my identifier here
and over here let me just return back
my
collection view
and over here i'm just going to pass
basically uh that collection view one
more time but first let me just type in
here system
background and over here let me just
type view dot add sub view
collection view or basically search
results collection view
over here i'm just going to
lay out my functions so basically um
collection view of the search results
basically the frame that is going to be
equals to
um the view the bounce
all right so basically one more thing
that we need to do actually i'm just
going to create over here so private var
titles that is going to be an array of
title
and let me initialize that array to be
empty for now
all right
and over here we just don't need to miss
that one more time so basically search
results collection view dot delegate
and that is going to be self
search results via controller
um i'm sorry search results collection
view the data source and that is going
to be self as well
over here let me just type in here
extensions
search results view controller let me
just
pass the delegates for here so
collection view delegate as well as the
collection view data source
so basically
number of
um section items in section basically
for now let me just type in here um
basically like something like 10
and here i'm just going to implement the
other data source function which is
basically sell for item
and let me just go ahead and type guard
let cell let me dequeue a new cell over
here so
dq with the reusable identifier let me
just choose um collection
view cell or basically what we have
called so um
yeah title collection view cell
identifier for index path
that is going to be as um title
collection view
and else we're just going to return the
normal ui collection view so
over here i can just specify something
like a background color for it and let
me just
return that cell one more time and um i
kept thinking about it basically we are
just designing for one screen size so
basically we can just
make it just a little bit dynamic so
that basically you can just try it on
multiple screens and i found that this
basically so basically ui
screen.main.bounds
the width
let's divide that by three
and maybe um we can subtract something
around um
five or ten
okay
and also i'm just going to um type in
here
um the minimum intermittent item spacing
i just need to set that so um zero i
guess that will work and let me just
build and run and let me see what do i
get so far
okay um top search let me just start by
typing anything over here so basically
you can see here um these are the cells
that are going to be responsible for
getting back
um the titles that we're going to be
searching for
all right
um and over here um i believe we can
test on another screen size so maybe um
the iphone 13
or um 13 pro i believe yeah i tested on
that once let's just go to the search
let me just try to type anything over
here and yes we have basically the same
uh dimensions across uh the
normal and the pro max or basically the
max
device
okay all right so let's go really quick
to our api caller
and over here we're just going to create
a new function so basically we're going
to type search
with
query
and that is going to be a type of string
and basically we're just going to return
the same
um signature over here so um let me just
copy the whole thing over here
so let me just paste in here so
basically we have a search function that
takes a query of type string
and basically we are just going to
change that url just right now just a
second let me just delete the url
because we are going to fetch a new url
but basically the same things goes over
here basically we are just going to pass
the url make the request serialize the
request using json object that we have
over here and then pass in here on the
completion and array of titles to the
caller so let me just go in here
and i have the developers website for
the movie database
dot org and i just clicked on search and
query for details and basically this is
going to be um an example for the the
url that we're going to uh basically
send our get a response or get request
to so let me just copy that
let me just go back in here and create a
new url so guard let url is going to be
url
that's going to be made of a string
and basically i'm just going to paste
that in here um also we can um
substitute that with the
with the constant here
that we have so basically let me just
type constants dot base url
and i believe yeah we need the forward
slash over here
and
instead of api key we're just going to
assign the constant that we have for
that so
constants.api key
and in here basically we are just going
to pass in the query that we have
all right
so basically our query is going to be
here but before passing the query we
just need to do something extra
but before
before this let me just go back in here
all right so before we send our query to
the url we just need to format that
query so first of all we are going to
type guard let
query that is going to be query dot
adding
percent
encoding and basically i'm just going to
pass over here so basically um url host
allowed all right
else return
and that basically takes care of
formatting the url so that we can use it
without any error all right so basically
we have everything set up over here so
um all right so let's just go back to my
um search controller over here search
review controller and then we just need
to configure the updater
to be this controller so basically let
me just type search
controller dot
um
i believe it's going to be yeah search
results of data and that is going to be
sell so basically xcode is just going to
throw some errors over here so basically
we just need to um import or conform to
that protocol
um
so let me just copy that over here and
basically let me just go down in here
extension
search view controller and i'm just
going to conform to that and now i'm
just going to implement one function
over here which is basically update um
search results all right so basically we
just need to um get the query from the
search bar so let me just type in here
let
search bar
that's going to be
equal to search controller dot search
bar
and over here i'm just going to write
guard
let
query
that is going to be
search bar dot text
and i just need to make sure that this
text um
is okay to be sent first so let me just
type in here um
query
dot
trimming characters
in white space so basically each white
space is going to be trimmed
and i'm just going to make sure that it
is not empty so i have to
invert that
all right any other thing i'm just going
to type in here the same thing so
basically query dot trimming in
white space
and i'm just going to get the count and
i'm also going to make sure that the
account is greater than or um or
basically
equals to three so basically we're just
doing that to try to minimize the calls
that we're going to make to the server
as much as possible so i don't just need
to call the server or basically send
anything to server if the search bar has
maybe like two characters or so
all right so um
also i just want to um set the
result controller so basically let
results
controller
that's going to be equal to search
controller
search results controller
as
search results view controller else i'm
just going to return so basically i'm
just setting the results controller to
to be of type search results view
controller and over here let me just go
and write results controller dot
delegate
okay just a second
and over here i'm just going to call the
function so let me just type api
caller.share.search
and that is going to take the query that
we have over here
and for this i'm just going to pass in
result and over here dispatch queue
dot main
dot async and over here we can switch on
the results
so result
okay
okay success
we have the um reference two titles over
here so basically
i'm just going to get the results
or basically let me just call that
titles
so results controller
dot
um i believe we have to um change that
maybe to public
because we want to access that from the
search view controller
so results controller dot titles that is
going to be equals to titles okay and
the results controller dot um also we
need to have access to the um to
collection view as well so let me just
go back in here
all right so change that to public as
well so now we can access that so let me
just go back to our search view
controller and over here i'm just going
to get the search results collection
view i'm just going to reload the data
over here
and as you can see here um basically we
didn't need to have like a weak self
because actually we're not using self
over here and now
i just need to handle the failure
and okay i'm just going to
you know
the usual which is basically printing a
localized description for the um
description uh which is basically
forgotten before the error
all right so let me just go back in here
search results controller instead of
having 10 elements by default i'm just
going to return return
the titles.count
and over here i'm just going to delete
that i have made sure that the cell is
working right now i can just configure
it to be working with the array that we
have so um
let me just get that over here so let
title
is going to be of um
titles
okay index path
dot row
and over here i have the information
accessible for each title
okay so basically cell
dot configure
and it just take a string over here
really this is going to be um the the
poster path
so i can pass in here title dot poster
path let me hit build and run and let me
see what do we get so far
okay
and i believe that same error that we
have basically it's just an optional so
i'm just going to give a default
of an empty string
okay
let me try to search for maybe harry
potter so harry
potter okay and as you can see here we
have um the search functionality is
working
okay so as you can see here i'd search
for google developer console and we're
going to click on the first link and
basically i've created a new account on
google over here so that i walk you
through how to enable this service on
your app so basically we're going to
click on credentials
all right and then google is going to
ask you first to create a project so
that's exactly what we're going to do so
basically let's just create project and
let me call that for example
netflix clone
and let me just
press create
all right so once it's finished we're
going to see this page so basically
we're going to just press on create
credentials and we'll just need to
choose the api key and basically this is
going to be the key that we're going to
use actually to access the youtube api
servers okay
so just
close that right now and as you can see
here your api key is stored under the
api key sections and basically you can
just copy that from here
all right so the next thing that we need
to do is actually enable the youtube api
service so let me just open the
dashboard one more time over here and
over here you're just gonna see the
enable apis and service we're gonna
click on that and over here we're just
going to scroll down until we see the
youtube data api basically we're just
going to click on that
and press enable
and that's it once it's finished we're
going to be able to use that to search
the youtube right so as you can see here
the youtube api services is already
enabled and as you can see here we have
the option to disable but we won't do
that actually so let me just go back to
my credentials and let me just get that
api key and let me copy that api key
let me fire up xcode and i'm gonna make
sure that you're in the api caller and
over here i'm just going to add this api
key so basically static
let
youtube api key i'm just going to paste
that in
so right now we're going to be able to
use that to search the youtube so let me
just go back to safari and let me go
over here and type youtube
api
and let me open the first link over here
and we're going to click on search for
content
as you can see here we have the
documentation on how to use the um the
api for youtube to make a search and as
you can see here we are searching with
the google um apis
slash youtube and the search so
basically um i know a way which is
basically very easy which is you can
just scroll down on here on the right
side of the screen and then click on
show code
and then click on the http and as you
can see here basically this is the going
to be the http link or the url that
we're going to use to fetch data from
the youtube
so basically uh we can scroll down here
um and you see this q basically this is
going to be our string that we're going
to pass or basically this is going to be
the string that we're going to search
for so let me just type in here for
example harry potter
and as you can see here uh it gets
updated over here and the space between
harry and potter is just um now percent
20 uh which we can do easily in xcode
and we have done that in the last video
as well so basically uh we're just going
to pass
our api key
in here so let me just um you know
make that easier to read so let me just
copy that
all right
and let me just go back in here to api
color i'm just going to create a new
function over here so let me just go
in
this section over here so let me just
type a new function which is going to be
func
get movie
with
query
that is going to be a type of string and
we're going to take care of the
completion function but later i'm just
going to right now create a url
so let me just dive in here let
url and that is going to be a url of a
string and over here i'm just going to
pass in the string that we have all
right um basically i can see here this
is going to be basically the same across
the urls that we're going to make so let
me just
go in here
and let me copy that
or cut that actually
and i'm just going to go over here i'm
going to type static let
youtube
base url
and that is going to be
equals to this
and instead i'm just going to pass that
one more time in here so let me just
type constants
dot youtube base url and now we have our
query over here i'm just going to take
that
from there from the search
function because it's going to basically
uh be the same
all right so let me just type in here
guard let query dot adding per set
encoding with allow characters url
allowed so basically that is going to
take responsibility for replacing the
white space with the percent 20 that you
saw earlier okay and right now i'm just
going to pass that in here
all right so now i have my query
and over here i'm just going to replace
that with my api key that we got earlier
so
youtube api key and basically that is
going to be the url so let me just guard
that out so guard let and that is going
to be um else
return and now we have our api url ready
to be used so right now i'm just going
to make um a task so let task or you
know what we can just copy that one more
time over here so
i'm just going to take that all
and i'm just going to paste that one
more time in here and as you can see
here basically we're just doing the same
things over and over again so i believe
it's pretty easy so um we haven't yet
decided the completion function uh what
will it do so let me just
instead of trying to decode that one
more time in here let's just for now
view the response that we're going to
get back from the youtube api so for now
i'm just going to print the error over
here
and here i'm just going to type json
serialization
dot
json object and that is going to come
from data and i'm going to
say fragments allowed and over here i
can just print that results
and we just need to fire up this um
function basically from outside so let
me just go to my home view controller
for now and we're going to change that
basically however
i just want to open the view load method
over here and over here i'm just going
to say api caller.shared.getmovie
and over here since we don't have a
completion function yet so i'm just
going to pass in a normal string so
basically harry potter
and let me build and run this and let me
see what do i get so far
all right so basically as we can see
here permission denied i believe
something wrong with the api so let's
just go back to the api caller and let
me see here um and basically yes we
forgot actually um i removed the key
parameter as well so let's just make
sure that you type that exactly like i
do over here
i just forgot to add the key
keywords so let me just hit build and
run one more time and let me see what do
i get
and as you can see here we managed to
get the response successfully from the
youtube server
so let's have a quick look on the
response that we get from the youtube
server as you can see here basically
there is an array of some sort of object
and that object has as you can see here
an attribute which is called id and
inside that id we have the video id that
we can use to search for the actual
video on youtube
so let me just copy that right here and
let me just go up in the models over
here and i'm just going to create a new
file and i'm going to name that
youtube
search response
all right and over here let me just
create a new struct let me give that
name of
youtube search results
and that is going to be
conforming to the protocol which is
codable
over here i'm just going to create
an item and we can just know
what we're gonna have by this so
basically we have an array of items
so
items
and that is going to be an array
of
maybe um
video element
so i'm just going to create that over
here so video
element
or yeah video element and that sounds
good
all right now xcode is going to complain
because it doesn't know what is video
element is and we just can
give that
a definition over here so structure of
video element that is going to be a
codable as well
and over here it's going to have
um maybe something like an id
so um let id that is going to be an
object as well
maybe we can call that um maybe
video element i'm sorry
video
element
or we can just call it id video
element
all right so right now we just need to
create that structure so struct
id video
or can just copy that name over here
so struct id
video element that is going to be
conforming to the codable protocol as
well and that should be having like two
fields the kind field and that is going
to be a string
and basically the
id
or video id and make sure to have the
same name over here world as well
so string but for the sake of simplicity
i'm not going to be using the kind but
i'll just leave it here so right now we
have the structure for or basically the
model for the youtube response
ready and also i can change that from
results to response
so it matches
the um the name of the file over here
all
right and now let's just jump in in the
api caller
and let's just complete our function
over here which is basically get movie
so i can just copy the same
um completion handler over here so let
me just
paste that over here so
let me just have the completion function
but instead of returning an array of
title
i'm just going to return a video element
from here
and you can just go back to the um
youtube search response and basically
the video element is going to have the
id
so let me just go back in here so i'm
just going to return a video element not
an array of video element make sure that
you have this right
and now instead of just realizing the
data over here i'm just going to decode
that so let me just have an instance of
the json decoder and now press decode
and over here i'm just going to use the
youtube
search response that i have
from the data
and over here i can just print the
results
and now let me hit build and run and let
me see what do i get
all right so we have an error over here
so let me just go and fix that really
quick
and basically the api shared um
get movie response that misses and uh
like um completion over here so let me
just
api color
shared dot get movie
all right so let me just pass in here
harry potter and over here i'm just
going to get the results i'm not going
to do anything with the results right
now let me just hit build and run
and let me see what do i get
all right so basically i have here an
array and that array as you can see here
has the best matches for the searches
that we have but more importantly um the
decoding went successfully and as you
can see here we can just access the
first
um the first object over here and it
does have like an id which is going to
be this that this is what we're going to
be using for searching the youtube
and now let me just go back to the api
color one more time
and instead of just um printing the
results over here
so just actually
return the results so the completion
that is going to take
success and for the video element i'm
just going to access the results
items and basically that is going to be
an array as you can see over here but
basically i just need the best search
option so i'm just going to access the
first element over here and if it's all
went wrong so let me just go and pass
the
failure over here so
i can pass the error
and that's it for the get movie function
alright so let me just go back to my
home view controller right now and
basically i want to delete this
basically i don't want the app to search
for harry potter each time i open the
app all right so let me just scroll down
over here
and as you can see here basically we are
rendering each section which its own
titles so basically we can just go back
in here title table view controller and
um i believe that's the one
um
okay
so yeah basically that's it that's the
one that we're looking for basically as
you can see here we are
rendering each cell which with the model
so basically we can just implement that
one more for over here so basically this
select
and make sure that you're in the
collection table view cell and i'm just
going to implement that function over
here so basically whenever i tap on any
title
first of all i just need first
to have a collection
view
dot deselect item and i'm just going to
deselect that one in the index path and
i'm just going to set the animated to
true
i'm just going to grab the title name so
let me just guard let title
name and that is going to be
all right so let me just grab the title
first so let title that is going to be
titles
all right
index bath dot row
and basically we have the title over
here so guard that title name that is
going to be title dot original title
name or
the title dot original
title
right and i can just
return if it's not going if it's empty
or basically if it's not
so basic i have the title name and over
here i can just say api
caller.shared.getmovie
and over here i can just pass in the
title name and as a little hack i can
just append the word trailer into it so
basically i can search youtube with that
exact same name plus adding the trailer
word next to it
and i can just get the result over here
all right so i'm just going to switch on
the result and in case of success let me
get that video element
all right and over here i can just print
the video element dot id
and if it all goes wrong maybe we can
just have another
um
case for the error or basically it's not
optional to be exact it's mandatory to
do so for example let me just print the
error over here and for now let me just
test that
so let me hit build and run
and over here maybe i can
have something like maybe
we can choose something like um
no time to die or do i'm just going to
choose that
and over here you can see that we have
made the request for the youtube server
and we have basically a returned object
which we can actually copy that
video id
and over here let me just open youtube
let me just open a new um
video for example let me just open that
one over here and as you can see here we
can
add this video id over there so let me
just paste that over here and let me hit
build and run and as you can see
basically we have the official main
trailer of the movie that we have
clicked on
and basically i'm just going to create a
new file and that is going to be a new
controller
so let me just make sure that i'm
choosing swift and for the name i'm just
going to say like something like title
preview
view controller and let me just hit next
all right so basically this is going to
be the controller in which we are going
to pass in the video and be able to view
the video actually so basically i'm just
going to import something over here so
let me just type import
webkit
and over here i'm just going to
initialize one more view so basically
private let web view and that is going
to be wk
webview
all right
and
let me just initialize that
all right so basically this is going to
be the view in which we are going to
view the video for the trailer and right
here let me just define a new label
title so private
let
title label
and that is going to be ui label
let me initialize that with the
anonymous closure pattern
so let label that is going to be ui
label
i'm just going to return the label over
here
and i just need to
enable the auto layout so basically
translate autoresizing mask into
constraints that is going to be equals
to false
all right and for the font i'm just
going to say let label dot
font and that it's going to be system
font
of size maybe 22
and for the weight i'm just going to
choose bold
all right
let me just initialize one more view
okay so private let
overview label and that is going to be
labeled as well
same pattern over here
so let label that is going to be ui
label
and i'm just going to return the label
one more time basically we're just doing
the same stuff over here so let label
font and that is going to be
um maybe something like 18
so system
wait
wait just a second so system
font that is going to be 18
and
for the overview i'm just going to say
regular
and i'm going to enable the auto layout
as well
just a second over here and maybe
since the label could take
multiple lines i'm just going to say let
label dot number of lines that is going
to be equal to zero and basically when
you set the number of lines in swift um
to zero that means that it can actually
take multiple lines that's not going to
be constrained for just one or two lines
all right
so um maybe i can have like something
like um a download button so
private let download button and that is
going to be ui button
let me initialize that so that button
that is going to be ui button
button dot translate auto resizing
constraints
false let me just return that button
and over here i can set the background
for the um 3d button maybe for something
like a red color
all right
and um
button not set title
that's going to say download
for normal
all right in
button.title
color
and that is going to be white also for
normal
all right so basically we just need to
add those views into our
so you don't add some view i just need
to add the web view
view dot add some view
maybe the title
you don't add some view
overview label
and you'd add some view that is going to
be the download button
and over here i just need to um
configure constraints
all right and let me create that
function down here
and this is going to be a function
all right so first of all i just need to
set
the um the web view
so
let me say something like um
let
web
view constraints
and that is going to be an array
and that array is going to take um some
constraints actually so webview
dot
top anchor and that is going to be
constrained with the view
top anchor
all right so um
webview
dot
leading anchor the constraints
to the view not leading anchor as well
web view
right
dot trailing anchor that is going to be
also constrained with the view
training anchor
and for the height
all right so high anchor that is going
to be somewhere around
[Music]
maybe 250
or
maybe we can just set assume that the
whip kit is just going to
um
calculate its height for now
all right so let me just type ns layout
constraints to activate and let me pass
the webview constraint all right so over
here let me just constrain the title as
well so let
title constraints or title label
constraints
and that is going to be an array as well
so
title label dot
top anchor
i'm just going to
constrain that maybe to the web
view the bottom anchor and that is going
to be spaced by maybe 20 points
all right
so
title label dot leading anchor
constrains and that is going to be
constrained with the view leading anchor
and maybe 20 points from the left as
well
so uh i believe that is enough for
displaying the title label so in this
layout constraints
activate title label constraints
all right
and also we need some title or subtitle
constraints for the overview as well so
um
let over
view
label
constraints and that's going to be an
array
so overview
label dot top anchor and that is going
to be constrained
with the title label
in the bottom anchor
20 points or maybe 15
overview label dot leading anchor
constraints and that is going to be
equals to the view
dot leading anchor and maybe add some
margin on the left so constant that is
going to be 20 as well so that we have
them aligned
and i believe that's it for the overview
so same stuff over here same stuff over
and over
and i believe that's it
so um let me just go and add some dummy
text over here so for the label i'm just
going to give that a text maybe
harry potter
and now so for the overview label
maybe uh something like um label text
and this is the best movie
ever to watch as a kid
and trust me that is true
all right so basically we have a webview
constraints we have title label we have
overview and you can just play around
with this maybe you can add the rating
or the votes number of votes
basically you can just utilize the
information that we got earlier from the
movie database over here but for the
sake of simplicity i'm just going to
create
a new view model over here
all right so let me just create a new
swift file
all right let me call that um title
preview
view model
and inside that i'm just going to create
a new construct let me just call that
title
right so title
preview
view model
and inside of here i just need the title
and that is going to be a string
i need the youtube video
so let
youtube video and that is going to be
maybe
video element
all right
and
for the title overview
all right so
that is going to be a string so
what do i need to do right now so um let
me just let me just see if everything is
working for the title preview controller
so over here inside the home view
controller i can just
navigate to this controller so um
navigation controller the
and inside that i'm just going to pass
in the title preview controller
and for the animation i'm just going to
say true and let me build and run this
and let me see what do i get so far
all right and as you can see here harry
potter is at the top
maybe we forgot to add some constraints
over here so let me just go back to the
title preview controller and
believe
something is wrong over here which is
basically
the web view the web view doesn't have
actually
the auto layout enabled so um i believe
i can do something about that so let me
just
define that with the enormous closure
pattern over here
and over here i'm just going to say let
web view
and that is going to be wk webview and
inside of here i can just say
webview.translate
all the resizing masks and that is going
to be equals to false and let me just
return the webview over here one more
time let me build and run and let me see
if that is working
and
it's not working yet so i believe we
have to add some sort of height
so um let me just say webview.com
anchor and that is going to be equals to
maybe somewhere like 250.
let me build on one
as you can see here we have the um the
webview
and
the title the um
and everything is working over here
maybe we can just add
an um
a constant over here for the top margin
i can set that maybe somewhere around
50.
let me build and run one more time
and over here this is going to be
the um
the web view that we're going to pass in
the video
url we just need to set the download
button we forgot that as well
so let
download button constraints
and there's going to be an array over
here so
download button and that is going to be
at the center of the controller
so um
center x
and that is going to constrain with the
view
dot center x
and for
that i'm just going to
add
maybe a top
margin between the button and the
overview maybe around 15 points so
let's just top anchor constraints and
that is going to be constrained with the
um overview label the bottom anchor and
let me just add maybe somewhere like 20
points
let me see if that is working correctly
um yeah we forgot to activate the
constraints as well so any layout or
constraints
um
all right so activate
download button constraints and let me
hit build and run and let me see what do
i get
and as you can see here basically the
download button it's over here it's
working fine
all right so um what do we need to do
right now basically i just need to set
the background color of the view so
background color and that is going to be
system background
let me hit build and run
all right so we have everything is
working over here i can just modify the
download button to look at it a little
bit nicer
so um
button
right so i can do that over here
basically so
download button
with an anchor and that is going to be
equal somewhere
around
120
all right so um yeah basically we just
need a separator over here so um yeah
that is that looks so much better
maybe um 140 that will look much nicer
and for the height as well we can just
send that
all right so
height anchor that is going to be
somewhere around
um
80
all right let me see if that is looking
good
so too much we can just play around with
the
um with the values of the height over
here until
you're satisfied with some something
okay um
i actually realized something maybe the
um the overview is just going to take
multiple lines so that doesn't have to
be
um yeah that's working fine okay
basically because we are just
constraining the top anchor of the
bottom to be below the overview level
with 25 whatsoever
and that is going to be only um
centered
horizontally
so um over here maybe we can add some
something to the download button so
button
dot layer dot um corner radius
and that is going to be equal to 15
one dot layer dot clips to bounce
or mask to bounce yeah that is going to
be true as well so let me just hit build
in one
right
maybe we can change that to eight but
you get the idea
um we're gonna move into something else
right now
um basically uh i just need to
[Music]
pass in the information over here but
basically we just need to configure the
controller before we initialized it so
let me just go back down in here
and i can create a new function
that is going to be
called configure
with
model
and that is going to take a title
preview view model
and over here i'm just going to set the
title label
dot text and that is going to be model
title
all right so the overview label dot text
is going to be model dot
title overview
and over here i'm just going to create a
new
url so guard
let
url
is going to be url
with string
and inside of here let me just type
https
colon forward slash
www.youtube.com
slash
embed
right
and over here i'm just going to pass in
um the url that we get
so model
dot
youtube video
all right so id
dot video id
and then else
i'm just going to return
so right now i have the url so i'm just
going to use that to load
inside the web view so webview.low
and that is going to take a url request
with the url that we have over here
all right so basically that's it so
let's just go to the collection table
view cell
and over here i'm just going to create a
new protocol so protocol
is going to name that
collection view table view cell
delegate
that's going to be a type of any object
inside that i'm just going to create a
new function
and basically that function is going to
be called collection view table view
cell
did tab
cell
all right and that is going to take an
um an object type
basically of um
all right so
cell and that is going to be over time
this
and also a model or view model to be
exact
and that is going to be the title
preview view model
all right and over here i'm just going
to create a private
or sorry that is going to be a weak
var
of delegate
and that is going to be of this type
and also it's going to be optional
all right so over here i'm just going to
get down to this
function over here did select item
and once i have basically the video
element over here
basically i'm just going to say delegate
dot
or write self
and inside here i'm just going to create
that view model
all right so let me just copy that over
here let me just take that out maybe to
be easier to see
all right
so let me just do that over here so let
view model
all right so
that is going to be of types um here i'm
just going to pass in the
uh the string for the title
so um that is going to be titles
all right
index path
row
and over here i'm just going to pass in
the original title
or
basically the original row and for the
simplicity i'm just going to get the
title over here
so
titles
index.path
row
and over here i'm just going to
change that basically to title
so title.original title or
the title
oh basically i have the title name
actually so that is gonna be much easier
all right
and also over here i have i have to
provide the video element
all right so um
let me just pass in the video element
over here
and also here i'm just going to get the
title
all right so title dot
overview
and i believe that is okay and just we
need to reference that using self and
since we're just going to use that
inside and uh or basically a synchronous
function i'm just going to say weak self
and over here let me say self
dot and don't forget the question mark
over here
so
um let me just maybe
guard that or force wrap that all right
over here let me just pass in the
overview but that needs to be unwrapped
first
so
let's
over
view
and that is going to be title
all right so let me just guard that out
so guard
let title overview dot title
dot overview
else
return
all right so let me pass the
title overview over here
all right i believe that is correct so
basically yeah that is correct from now
and over here i'm just going to pass in
the view model
that we have created over here and here
i'm just going to pass in self
but i need to guard that first out so
guard let
strong self that is going to be equals
to self
else
return
and basically self is over here as an
optional
so let me just pass in the strong self
over here
and let me build and run and let me see
what do i get so um
all right so basically we just need to
add
an optional self over here and let me
build and run this and let me see yeah
basically we don't have any errors right
now
so let me just go to the home view
controller i'm just going to create a
new extension for that controller
and that is going to confirm to our
protocol that we've just created earlier
which is collection view table view cell
delegate
and over here
i'm just going to implement that
function
so uh basically we're going to have the
title preview
view model over here so let me just say
let vc that is going to be a title
preview view controller
and over here i'm just going to
configure
that with the view model that we have
from here
so view model and now i'm just gonna
say navigationcontroller.push
and that is going to be equals to vc and
i'm just going to set the animation for
true let me just go up in here and let
me just take that out which is basically
um
this line over here we don't need this
anymore we have everything set up over
it now so let me just build and run this
and let me see what do i get so far
so um i'm pretty sure that is going to
work i'm i doubt it but let's just try
so let's just click on the ghostbuster
over here and let me see what do i get
basically nothing and that is because we
forgot to set our delegate
to the be
this
controller so um
basically i'm just going to get
um down over here and before i
do this so let me just say vc.delegate
and that is going to be self
and over here let me just go
and make the um
[Music]
all right so the delegate is going to be
in the collection view cell over here
so i'm just going to need to access this
all right so um let me just go to um
yeah let's just go to the uh do the
table view cell i believe
so
home view controller
and let me just scroll up button here
all right so table view cell all right
so let me have this so sell for row okay
so let me just sell
delegate and that is going to be equals
to self
alright so let me just hit build and run
one more time
and i hope that is going to be working
so uh yeah basically just delete this
that doesn't make any sense
so let me build a run
and i believe that is going to work so
ghostbusters
and we have an error over here
all right so basically this is the error
that we have over here and it we can fix
that really quick so let me just say
um this patch
q
main dot async and over here i'm just
going to
have those lines cut and paste it over
here i believe that's it and that is
going to work
so let's just cross our fingers
and basically i just need to have um
reference for this week's self
and i'm just going to add
this over here so self
optional
and
yeah basically i just need to say in
all right so let me just build and run
let me see if that is working so
ghostbusters and you can see here
basically the uh the name of the movie
uh the overview and we can just type
press on that let me just see if that is
working and indeed that is actually
working so basically we just need to fix
the overview title um constraints over
here and actually it's pretty easy to
fix so we just need to go to the title
preview controller over here and
basically there is one constraint that
we forgot to add which is basically the
trailing anchor for the uh overview text
so overview
label dot trailing anchor and that is
going to be constrained with the view
dot trailing anchor over here let me
just hit build and run one more time and
let me see if i have the
title overview is constrained in its
place so let me just hit ghostbusters
and as you can see here basically
everything seems to be working fine
maybe you can just add
a little bit extra height
for this i believe it would look so much
better so maybe
300 let me hit builder on one more time
and let me see what do i get as a final
results and yes indeed i am so satisfied
with the results for now
all right so let me just pump the phone
just a little bit so that we can see
more clearly and let me just close that
and basically before actually starting
implementing that event handler or
basically tapping handler i just need to
change something regarding the how the
app works as you can see here basically
we don't actually fetch any new movie or
any new title and pass that to our
header view over here basically we're
just viewing the static image that we
have passed earlier inside the assets
folder so let me change that basically
i'm just going to define a new variable
here now it's going to a private
variable and let me just call that
random
selected movie or basically a random
trending movie and that is going to be
type title
all right
and basically i just need to make that
an optional for now so it can actually
be nil for now and we're just going to
change that later
all right and the second thing that we
need to do actually uh we're going to
change the scope of this header view as
you can see here basically it's only
visible inside the view that load
because it's just local variable so
we're gonna make
that change so let me just type in here
private
header
view
and that is going to be of type hero
header view and that is going to be
optional as well so it can actually be
nil
and right now uh i just need to say var
yeah i forgot var actually and it's not
constant because that is going to change
just just over here so let me just
delete this and now we have a reference
to header view and outside the view load
method and now i'm just going to create
a new function and that function is
going to be called configure hero header
view
and inside that function i just need to
make a new
get request from the server so that i
can pull some trending movies and assign
one randomly to that random trending
movie variable
so let me just do that so api caller
though share don't get trending movies
and over here i'm just going to get the
result and as usual we're just going to
switch on the result and basically we're
just going to implement the success case
and also the failure case so let me just
do that so case success i'm just going
to get an array of titles and basically
i'm just going to set that to
my random
right so random trending movie and that
is going to be to one of those titles
and that is going to be get randomly and
over here i just need to have a weak
reference of self so that i can do that
easily
all right so basically let me just
implement the failure
case as well so let error and basically
i'm just going to print the error
all right so error the localized
description yeah that is a dot not a
comma so a localized description so
basically i just made my api call for
the server and i retrieved back some
titles over here and i got one randomly
and i set that to my random trending
movie title of type title so right now i
just need a function so that i can
configure the header that is being
displayed in the hero view so let me
just do that so let me just open the
hero header view over here and basically
i just need to implement one more
function so basically it's going to be
public because i'm just going to access
that from outside so
configure
with model
and basically that is going to be
uh i believe something like um the view
model over here so yeah title
view model
all right and over here i just need to
access this hero image view
so um let me just copy that again i
forgot the word font and let me just
copy that from
maybe the title um table view cell i'm
just going to copy that url because i'm
actually going to pass in the poster url
as well and that is going to be a
constant that's not going to change
whatsoever so let me just go back to
hero header view again i got my url from
the title table view cell so hero header
view and just going to you know add this
url over here and now i'm just going to
access this so hero image view
dot
sd set image and that is going to be set
with a url and for this is that is going
to be nil for the completion and
basically that's it i believe that is
going to work so let me just help
billion run and let me see what do i get
so far
all right and nothing changed over here
i guess i forgot actually to call this
method
so what do i have here so yeah we have
just set that to a random um trending
movie element and over here i'm just
going to say
optional self
header view
dot configure and that is going to be
configured with the title view model
over here
basically we're just going to pass in
the same um
random element that we have chosen so
let me just do that over here so let's
select the title
and that is going to be titles
all right so titles
dot random element and basically i'm
just going to reuse that over here so i
don't generate a new random element
all right
so basically let me grab this
title so basically this selected title
i'm just going to pass that in here so
select the title
dot
um original title or just empty string
for now
and basically i'm just going to do the
same here so selected title
dot
um poster path
or an empty string for now so i believe
that should be working yes we have no
errors and actually i forgot to call
this method from here so configure
header view or hero header view and let
me just tell build and run and let me
see what do i get so far
all right so basically uh we are now
generating random element each time we
open the app let me just confirm that
let me
close the app let me reopen it one more
time and basically yes each time we open
the app we have new random element
generated so right now let's just start
working on actually making each title
can be tapped anywhere because as you
know it's only tapped within the home
view controller over here
so now let's just get this thing to work
so let me just go to the upcoming view
controller and let me implement a new
function over here so basically i'm just
going to implement table deselect row at
and basically i'm just going to
reference that table one more time over
here and say deselect row and index path
and set the animation to true for now it
doesn't really matter but basically i
just need to have a reference to the
title that i have just pressed on so
titled that is going to be titles
index path dot row and now i have the
title already so let me just say
guard
let title name and that is going to be
title dot original title or the title
dot original name
else
i'm just going to return so basically i
have the title name that i have just
pressed on so what do i need to do right
now basically i'm just going to say api
color dot shared dot get movie and i'm
just going to pass in the title name
over here and for the result i'm just
going to switch on the result as well so
case success basically i have a video
element so let's video element
and the other one is going to be case
failure and i'm just going to get an
error which i'm going to be printing
just normal
so error dot localize description and
over here i just need to
make a new um
a new instance basically for the preview
controller which i'm going to actually
be pushing um inside the navigation
controller so i'm just going to say let
vc and that is going to be
um title preview view controller and
over here i'm just going to configure
that with the title view model that i
have over here so basically for the
title i can just pass in the title name
and for the youtube video i'm just going
to get the video element and for the
title overview i have the title over
here and i can say just here
um overview and i believe that's it
all right so basically i just need to
push the view controller over here uh
basically that is that needs to be
unwrapped or you know i can just add
like an empty string over here and that
should take the error away all right so
um let me just say here
weak self
all right and over here i'm just going
to say self which is going to be an
optional so i'm going to say navigation
controller the push view controller and
that is going to be my vc over here and
i'm going to say true let me just hit
build and run and let me see and just
need to go to the coming soon
and press on any
movie over here let's just say sun
and that is going to take me directly to
one of those but i have an error over
here which is basically yeah i know how
to fix that so let me just go
really quick over here and basically we
just need to add that to a dispatchq dot
main dot async i always forget that so
basically let me just
take that cut and paste that over here
build and run one more time and i
believe that is going to work definitely
is going to work and
yeah basically that is working fine so
the upcoming is already done so let's
just go to the top search really quick
and i believe it's going to be really
the same so i can actually copy that
function over here so table view cell i
believe that is going to be exactly the
same so let me just go down in here and
inside the delegate methods of the table
let me just paste that one more time
and i believe that is going to work yeah
there's no error whatsoever so let me
just hit build and run one more time
and go to top search spider-man and yeah
that is basically working
fine
all right so now we have the search
results view controller remaining and
that is going to be just a little bit
tricky because we're not just accessing
the title within the navigation
controller tabs over here we're just
navigating
we're just accessing the title from
another um place so we're just going to
use protocols and delegates so let me
just go to the search results view
controller over here and over here i'm
just going to create a new protocol so
protocol and let me just call that uh
maybe search
results view controller delegate
and that is going to be of type any
object and inside of here i'm just going
to create a new function
so funk
and that is going to be called search
results view controller
all right so let me just
do this so
search results view controller did tab
item and that is going to take
basically the view model
all right so and that is going to be
titled preview view model all right so
basically over here i just need to
create the public weak
var and that is going to be delegate and
that is going to be of the same type of
the protocol over here and that's going
to be optional because i will not be
initializing that right away
and basically i just need to go down
here inside my collection view
and i'm just going to say collection
view that select item i just need to
have the collection view instance over
here and i'm going to say deselect item
at index path and that is going to be
true and inside of that i'm just going
to reference my delegate and i'm going
to say search results did tab item and
basically i'm just going to pass in this
item
so basically i just need to have the
title over here so um let title
and that is going to be titles
or write
index path
row basically i have my title over here
um i can pass in the name as well so um
alright or you know you can just say
title dot original title and i can
pretty much say that is going to be
working without actually the need of um
accessing the original name as well and
for the youtube video i just need to
have this video element so basically
before actually saying the delegate
search result tab item i just need to
grab the video element first and
basically i can just go to the upcoming
and basically i can just copy this
from here i believe
yeah basically it's going to be the api
color function so let me just grab that
function over here because basically
we're just going to be doing the same
thing
so
um
all right so api callershare.getmovie
and basically i'm just going to get the
name and that name is going to be from
the title all right so
original title or empty string for now
and i'm pretty sure that is going to be
working
all right so let's see over here um
dispatch q
vc from the title preview view
controller basically i just need to have
the same thing over and over here so
let's just
say let title name and that is going to
be equals to this
all right
and instead that you can just pass in
the title name over here title name that
is going to be working
um i believe yeah same thing over and
over
and i can say well i can just copy this
function over here
all right so what do i have um
basically in case of the success
i have the video elements so basically i
can just remove the dispatch queue over
here because that is going to be done
from the search view controller so
instead i'm just going to say delegate
all right so i just need the weak self
as well so self
all right so basically self dot delegate
search results view controller that is
going to say did tab item and i'm going
to say the item that was just tapped is
just going to be the title with that
name and the video element i just got
that video element over here and for the
title overview same thing over and over
so basically title dot overview and i
can just pass an empty string from there
basically
this is completely done from the search
results view controller now we just need
to go to the search view controller over
here and just swipe up until we see this
um initialization for the search results
view controller basically we're not
making a global variable so that we can
access that search results view
controller anywhere else but there's
another cool way that we can actually do
this which is basically
the search controller over here
basically we have the results controller
which is basically the same thing
so
um basically i just need to say results
controller.delegate and that is going to
be self and once i'm done with that i
can actually um say that i'm going to
conform to the search results
view controller delegate over here and
down in there i can just say
search results did tab item and
basically i have my view model over here
so the thing i'm just going to be
need to do is actually say
navigationcontroller.push
and i'm just going to access this which
is going to be from here so let vc and
that is going to be title preview view
controller i'm just going to configure
that with the view model that i have and
then i'm just going to pass in the view
controller and say true for the
animation let me just hit build and run
and let me confirm that this is working
so let me just hit spiderman and i have
spiderman over here let me say that it's
going to be working yeah basically we
just fell with the same error over and
over again
so let me just say dispatch q dot main
dot async and inside of here i'm just
going to add that
right in here i believe that is going to
be working so yeah we just need to
mention that is going to be self so
weak
self
in and inside of here i'm just going to
say self optional dot build and run and
pretty much that is going to be working
i promise you so spider-man and
yes that is working as well so as you
can see here i'm in my home view
controller and let me just build and run
this project one more time so let me
demonstrate something basically we can
click on any title over here and it will
take us directly to the detail preview
controller where we can view some
information about the title like the
overview the title itself and we can
also watch the trailer but actually we
don't have any way of downloading the
title so that it can get into this tab
so basically this is what we're going to
be doing so let me just go to the
collection view table view cell and
scroll down at the bottom over here so
basically i'm just going to implement
one more function and basically this
function is going to be called
collection
view context menu configuration for item
at yeah this is a very long name for a
function but this is basically what
we're going to be using for downloading
the
title so let me start by defining this
so let
config and that is going to be ui
context menu configuration and we're
going to be using the default
constructor over here so let me just
have those
um parameters on just one line so that
it can be easier to read so for the
identifier i'm going to be passing nil
for the preview provider might be
passing nail as well and i'm gonna hit
return or enter on this
so basically let me just pass nothing in
this function and over here i'm just
going to
um initialize my actions so basically
let me have a download action
and that is going to be ui
action and that is going to be defined
with this so basically for the title i'm
just going to be passing download
all right so for the subtitle now
image nil
identifier nil
discover ability title and that also
gonna be nil and here's the best part
about it so the attributes we can just
delete it we can just forget about it we
don't need that
and for the state i'm going to say off
and for the handler let me just pass in
here for now so basically
download
tapped
all right so basically we just need to
exit about this so let me just return a
ui menu
and i'm just going to
be passing this so um
for the title i'm going to be passing an
empty string for the image nil
identifier nil and for the options that
is going to be a display in line and for
the children i'm going to have an array
in which we are going to be passing the
download actions or basically if we have
more than actions over here
all right so let me just before i exit
this um method i just need to return the
configuration i believe uh
i messed up in here so return
config
and basically that's it so let me just
hit build and run i believe i don't have
any errors yeah that is correct and now
let me just try that so let me just long
tap on spiderman over here and as you
can see here this cool animation uh
which blurs the background behind the
title and if i clicked on or tapped
actually on download you can see here
it's on the console download tapped so
basically right now we have a way so
that we can actually tell the app that
we want to download something
all right so now let's just dive in
inside um the basics of core data um
before i do so actually i just need to
um
make this like a little bit better to
read and
okay so let me just follow me over here
so basically i'm going to be defining a
new function so basically that is going
to be private func
and i'm going to call that function down
load title
at
and i'm going to say here index
path and that is going to be of type
index path
all right and basically over here i'm
just going to call that function from
down there so let me just type in here
um basically
uh weak self so weak self
and here i'm just gonna be typing self
optional
download title ad i'm gonna be passing
the index path path over here
so um right here i can just go to the
download title at and i can say print
downloading
and i'm gonna be uh accessing the titles
over here with the index path dot row
and over here i can just say like the
original title let me just hit build and
run one more time so that i can make
sure that everything seems to be working
fine
uh right so long press on the spider-man
download and i can as you can see here
downloading uh that is gonna be an
optional string which is basically
spider-man so basically we have now a
clean way for downloading things so now
let me just talk about a lot more about
core data
so
um let me just hit uh file new
um
project and
yeah don't worry about it we're not
gonna be creating a whole new project
from the start so let me just choose
that swift as you can see here basically
we have an option which is basically use
core data some of you all might be
thinking well when we started this
project we haven't actually uh checked
this uh use core data so basically we
need this inside our project so how do
we add core data to an existing project
that was initialized without core data
basically uh we're going to be making
this as a test project
all right and we're going to be
clicking on that we're not going to be
talking a bit uh in this video about
cloud kit um maybe in the future
tutorials but let's for now check use
core data
and i'm going to be tossing this project
maybe on the desktop for now
all right so yeah replace that because i
already had one with the same name and
as you can see here basically we have
test project file which is basically a
model for our database and also if you
looked inside the app delegates
basically you're going to see here code
data is imported and if you scroll down
basically you're going to be seeing two
variables or two functions over here
basically the persistent container and
also the save context i'm going to be
talk a little bit more about this but
for now let me just copy the entire
thing from here for so basically from
the mark that says core data stack i'm
going to be copying everything down to
the bottom i'm going to be closing this
project we're not going to be using that
project ever again so let's just go back
to our project which is going to be the
app
uh that we're being that we're going to
be build
here which is basically netflix loan um
let me just go to appdelegate and move
down here and let me just paste that
so
right now we just need to create a new
um all right so what do i have here
so uh yeah that was uh basically outside
the class so
yeah make sure that you know you don't
get outside this class
um
all right so maybe i forgot one
uh all right let me just hit build and
run
yeah everything seems to be working
all right so i believe something is
wrong in here yeah i actually got this
error because i forgot to import
core data and i'm not going to be
cutting or
editing this video because i want you
guys to see the problems that i face um
basically when i
implement or add core data to a project
that hasn't been initialized uh
previously with core data so as you can
see here basically we have imported core
data and also we uh pasted the safe
context method and also the persistent
container and we're going to be talking
a lot more about those but let me just
continue you know configuring core data
inside the app so let me just hit file
new or basically i just need to make
sure that i'm in my root directory let
me just right click on here new file and
scroll down until you see the core data
section and i'm gonna be choosing data
model
all right so this data model i'm gonna
be calling that maybe netflix clone
model
and very basic name and as you can see
here let me just go back to the app
delegate and i'm going to make sure that
this name over here matches this one so
netflix chloe model so i'm going to be
calling this
netflix clone
and you know it's case sensitive
all right so let me just talk a little
bit more about the persistent container
and the safe context um basically some
of um some of people some some of the
people actually in the community uh
called this as a context
manager and basically this is gonna be
an
variable which is going to be holding
the persistent container
or maybe you can say the database itself
so basically this is the place where
we store our data and basically this is
the context manager or basically the
manager um who's responsible for taking
the data from us
and committing those changes or actually
inserting this data inside the
database
so here how it goes let me just go on to
netflix clone model over here and
basically i'm going to be creating a new
entity right so um you can just
press on add entity at the bottom right
here and as you can see here basically
we have an entity i'm going to be
changing that name maybe to title
item
all right and basically we have
attributes and data types and if that
looks familiar basically it's something
like the models that we have for the
cycle over here so basically for the
title we have some attributes and we
have the data types um basically i'm
gonna be copying these uh into this uh
model that i have over here so let me
just make like a new tab
i believe i can open both of those like
um side by side so let me just um yeah i
did that by hitting command t
so um yeah that's not possible i guess
so all right so
for now let me just hit um on the plus
um symbol right here or the plus sign
over here so let me just start by typing
original
underscore name and that is going to be
string
all right so also i have original
title
and that is going to be a string as well
so basically i'm just copying the model
over here so i'm going to be fast
forwarding this part inside the video so
i don't waste your time
all right so as you can see here
basically i have the id which was um
integer inside my struct over here so
basically i chose the type uh to be
integer 64 and yeah please choose
integer 64 because i believe if you
chose something uh below this that might
give you an error so this is basically
that is going to be having like enough
space to hold the uh the id which is
been stored inside the structure over
here media type that is going to be a
string original name string original
title overview poster path um release
date vote average that is going to be a
double because i believe that is going
to be having like a decimal point and
for the vote count i believe it's also
an integer so basically we have that and
also i just want to make sure that we
have this um
file or this model um available to
access across xcode so let me just hit
command b
to build the um the application and i'm
going to be um searching for the title
that we have over here basically title
item and i'm gonna see here if that is
accessible from uh
from the project itself so let me just
go to maybe the collection table view
cell
and over here let me just make sure that
that this is accessible so title item
and as you can see here it's not so um
sometimes xcode
does this so it's normal so we can just
close xcode over here yes stop tasks and
just open xcode once again and i believe
that is going to work um so let me just
go back to the collection table view
cell and let me just type in here title
item and as you can see here basically
now xcode sees the um the type that we
have made inside the netflix clone model
that we have over here
all right so what we want to do right
now basically before we start making
anything to
core data i'm going to be going to the
managers over here because i just wanted
you to learn the the clean way actually
of implementing core data so let me just
create a new swift file and i'm going to
be calling that
maybe um
data
persistence
manager
all right so basically that class is
going to be responsible for
downloading the data and also to uh to
work and talk to core data api because
we don't want actually to talk to core
data api from within the class that
we're using for viewing the collection
view cell itself this is not solid
principle so i'm going to be using this
data persistent manager so let me just
say class i'm going to be copying this
name basically yeah i like that name
actually so
data persistence manager
and here right here let me just type
static let shared i'm going to be
creating like a shared instance across
the app
so um yes that we have here and right
now let me just define a new function
i'm going to be called that function
maybe download
title
with
model and that model i believe is going
to be a title
all right so let me just type that right
so basically this is what we're going to
be doing so basically we're going to be
downloading a title with model that is
going to be passed
from inside the collection table view
cell and also i want to have like a
completion handler over here
so completion that is going to be
escaping
and basically we want to return a result
and that result should have like a void
all right um and also um error if an
error happens
and that closure should return like a
void at the end so basically that's what
this is what we're going to be
implementing right here so right now we
just need to have our context manager be
able to insert the data that we want or
basically the data that we get from the
model here inside the database so
basically it's just a two-step process
first of all we tell the um the
model or basically the context manager
that we want to save something and we
tell it exactly what we're going to be
saving inside our database and then tell
the context api or the context manager
hey
all right this is the data that we have
been telling you please store that data
inside our database so first of all we
just need to have a reference to the api
um persistent container over here and
also
the uh the save context manager
so let me just go back to the data
persistence all right so let me just
type guard let because this is going to
be an optional so let me just type app
delegate
and that is going to be ui application
as
app delegate
else we're going to be returning
all right so i forgot else
so um yeah let me just type also over
here and over here i'm going to be
returning so right now i have like an
instance or basically a reference to the
app delegate and over here i just need
to uh have the context as well so um let
context and that is going to be um app
delegate
dot
resistant container dot view context
basically those are the two lines that
we need to be able to talk to the
context manager
all right so basically we just need to
import core data over here so that we're
going to be able to use core data
and over here i'm just going to create a
new item so basically let's item and
this item is what we're going to be
storing inside our database so let's
item and that is going to be
a title item
and we're just going to choose this one
with the context and we're gonna pass
the context over here so basically uh we
are going to um to create a title item
with the uh supervision of the context
manager over here so if this is the most
simple way that you can think about it
so hey context manager we are creating a
title item under your supervision so
please note that so okay so we right now
have an item
and over here uh we can just say
original title and that is going to be
model dot original title and basically
uh we're going to populate
all of the um
all of the attributes over here so item
id that is going to be model dot id
item dot uh what is uh also original
name model dot original name item dot
overview model dot
overview i hope that is making sense to
you guys because uh yeah
core data is not that simple to wrap
your head around um and basically yeah
we can see here like an error because
we're converting from an integer to
integer 64. but that could be fixed
easily so basically we're just going to
make um n64 and pass the model id over
here
um
let's just go
and
implement the other things so um what
else so media type and now it's going to
be model.media type item dot
poster path all right so model the
poster path um two three four five six i
believe we have three left so item dot
release date model dot release date
item dot vote count here and
average or the vote average here model
dot
uh vote count item dot um
all right so average
yeah both average that is going to be
model vote average as well so basically
as you can see here we have uh
everything when it comes to the um
saving the data so yeah let me just
replace that as well so basically we uh
we created like a title item that should
be um
saved inside the database and we created
this with the supervision of the
context manager now the context manager
needs our basically he is just waiting
for us to order uh that we want actually
to save the
title item inside the database so let me
just do that so context
and we're gonna say save
and basically that is going to throw an
error so basically we're just going to
wrap this inside the do catch block so
um yeah
let me just say try
right context dot save
and for the catch block i'm going to say
print
error dot localized description i
believe that is it
um
all right so let me just hit build and
run yeah that is succeeded and basically
if we managed to save the data over here
let me just um say okay completion
all right so basically we just need to
pass something over here all right so
basically we're just gonna pass the
results so the result is success and as
you can see here basically we are
expecting void to be passed but how
we're gonna be uh passing void this is
gonna be tricky because we can't just
type void this is a type name not not
like a data itself
well the best part about swift it's just
really really simple we just need to
pass an empty something so basically
we're going to be passing like an empty
parenthesis over here so as you can see
here basically once we are done saving
the data we are just going to pass the
completion to the um
or basically the success case to the
completion and over here uh once we
print the function i can just you know
instead of printing the
error over here i can just say
completion
well the failure and for the error
actually i can just you know be smart
about it so let me just go up here and
make an enum
and that is going to be like um a
download or basically a database error
and that is going to be getting from
error as well and we have here a case
let me just call that
failed
to save
data
and let me pass that word over here so
um database error
dot failed to save data and now uh
everything looks clean
and now we have one thing to do with
which is basically uh fetching the data
back from the server
uh but we're going to be doing this
later so let me just make sure that this
is working so let me just go to
collection table view cell
and over here so since we are
downloading a title so let me just
say data persistent manager shared
download title uh with model so
basically the model itself is going to
be titles
all right at index path
the row
and for the completion and look how
clean is that actually so basically we
have result we're going to be switching
on result
all right so switch
result and in case of
success
all right
so we don't
have anything over here so let me just
say print
downloaded
to
database
and in case of the failure we can just
print the error so
case failure and we have an error over
here passed from the data persistence
manager so error and please write here
like print
failed or basically yeah we have an
error information would be just
like
localized description for the error and
that's it so basically let me build the
um the project right here
and let me say
well we wanna like
download spiderman uh long tap on
spiderman
press download and as you can see here
download to database so that means
actually that we have successfully um
implemented everything correctly and now
um our
title is inside our database now it's
just a matter of fetching those or
fetching that title again
so
basically uh what do i want to do
basically when i tap on the download i
just need this to be reflected on in my
downloads manager over here or the
download step so before we do anything
inside of here let me just go to the
upcoming view controller i'm going to be
scrolling up in here um
yeah maybe i'm going to be
copying this so um
title and the yeah the title basically
the configuration for the title so um
let me just go in here
say downloads
all right let me hit build and run and
let me go to the download
tab and yes basically that is basically
what we're going to be getting and also
we need to implement like a simple table
view and that is going to be really
really simple because we're going to be
copying everything from the upcoming
through view controller
so basically let me just
um have that in here
and
yeah private
yeah basically
private let's instead of upcoming table
maybe we can say download the table
and over here i'm going to say download
the table dot delegate it's going to be
equal to self
download table data source that is going
to be equal to self as well and before
um like waiting for xcode to throw any
error inside of here so
download view controller that is going
to conform to ui table view
delegate and also ui table view data
source
all right so
number of table uh rows i believe we're
gonna be actually copying everything
from the upcoming view controller i'm
not i'm not sure why i did that at the
first place
so
we're gonna have this and that and that
and also yeah basically those three
functions
so let me just
um paste that in here and basically
we're gonna have this uh yellow usb
because we don't actually have titles
and basically we're gonna be creating
that over here so private let
titles and that is going to be an array
but instead of an array of title i'm
just gonna be having like array of title
item because that is going to be fetched
directly from the database
all right so um yeah let's just do
this to be a var instead of title or
instead of constant to be act to be
exact and title item and i'm going to be
initializing that away over here so we
don't have any error inside the function
or inside that class
so what do we need to do right now
basically we need to fetch the data from
the database and basically we're going
to be implementing that function inside
of the data persistence as well
so basically let me just go in here
all right and i'm going to be calling a
new function which is going to be
fetching
titles
from database
all right and that
should like give me a completion
so
completion
all right and that is going to be
escaping as well and i'm just going to
return like an array or basically a
result
and that result should have like
something like an array of
title item and also an error
and that closure itself is going to be
giving me like a void so basically when
we call that function we are expecting
to get an array of title item so what do
we need to
talk to the context manager again
basically the same thing over and over
here basically we just need to have this
copied um some of y'all might be asking
well you are just copying and pasting
well maybe this is just two lines code
uh it's not that big a deal actually
so right now we just need to talk again
with the context manager because
this manager is the only one responsible
or the only one authorized to access the
database inside our app so we need to
address the
context manager politely and hence we're
going to be making a request for that
context manager so let me just type let
request and that is going to be an
nsfetch request and that is going to
take the type of the data that we're
going to be querying from the database
so basically let me just type title item
all right so basically this is going to
be the type of the request that we're
gonna be using and now let me just sign
request dot
title item dot fetch
request so basically we now have our
request ready to be executed or
basically ready to be dispatched for the
context manager
so now we just need to dispatch the
request
for
the database context manager so
basically we're just gonna be doing that
inside of a do catch block because
accessing the database inside the app
and you might be um not be able to
actually find your request there that
might throw an error so for now at least
let me just print
error.localized description but let me
just go in here basically we are
asking the context manager would you
please ask the database with our request
and what is my request basically i'm
just going to fetch some title item so
basically let's do let's do that so let
me just try to convince the manager so
that he can like access the database so
we're going to be saying try like
context
dot fetch and please fetch the database
with the request that we have over here
and i believe that you're going to be
getting us back like some titles
and those titles are basically i'm just
going to pass those back to you know
um
the result that i have over here so
basically let me say let and if in case
of success i'm just expecting to have
like a title item which is basically
what we have over here and for the catch
that might be an error so basically
we're just going to say completion dot
failure
and over here i'm just going to pass the
same um operation or i'm sorry the same
error that we initialized earlier so
maybe um
database error dot fail to save data or
basically we can just have like another
case so case failed
all right so fail to
fetch
data and i can actually pass that over
here so fail to fetch data
so right now we have our um
fetching request done so let me just go
back to the download controller over
here and basically i just need to like
make a new function
so yeah basically we are creating
multiple functions in this tutorial so
private
func fetch
local
storage
for downloads and that is a mouthful
um name for a method but you know it's
pretty much describing what it does so
let me just say data persistence the
shared download no no download actually
i'm just going to fetch
or basically fetching titles from
database and when you
get the result i'm going to be switching
on the result one more time so basically
in case of success i'm gonna be having
like titles
that is going to be um
basically uh assigned to my
you know titles over here so let me just
have like a week reference so that we
don't uh be prone to any memory leak so
weak self and over here i'm going to be
saying self dot titles that is going to
be equal to titles and also i just need
to reload my
um
table views so let me just say like um
self dot table
view
or download
yeah download the table and that is
going to be
reloaded
i believe that's it for the success let
me just go in here for the failure i'm
going to have the error and i'm going to
be printing the error
just like normal in
like what we've been doing since the
beginning of the program
um basically i'm just going to call that
function over here so basically fetch
local storage for download and before i
run this app i might be
uh like i don't want you guys to like
run the app and don't see anything on
screen because we haven't actually laid
down the uh title uh or basically the
download table so let me just say lay
down yeah if you did layouts of views
super view the layouts of views download
the table frame that is going to be
viewed about and i believe that is going
to be working and remember in the last
time that we've run our apps so
basically we have downloaded spiderman
so i believe when i click on downloads
yeah basically there's nothing in here
so um
yeah let me see what did i miss so okay
um
yeah let's just do that again so replace
so um let me just download spiderman
download
and since it's downloaded to the
database so i can go to the downloads i
don't see anything so let me just close
the app open the app one more time and
go to downloads i still don't see
anything over here
and let me see actually why do i have
something like this so let me just debug
this really really quick so let me just
make sure that i'm here
so
all right so
okay we are here we have everything over
there so i believe that we need to
dispatch
you know uh this inside like
a synchronous
or on the main thread to be exact so
dispatch q
dot main dot async
and we are just going to get that over
here
all right so let me just hit build
around let me see
if i do have it
um i still don't have it i don't see any
reasons why we shouldn't actually have
it so let me just debug this really
really quick
oh how silly i am so basically we forgot
actually to add the table view inside of
here so view dot add sub view
download table
and
i believe that is going to work so let
me just go to downloads and as you can
see here basically we have spiderman
downloaded twice
so um
yeah so basically we just need actually
to implement one more function inside
the data persistence which is going to
be a delete function let me just
implement that function really quick so
let me just type func delete
title
with
model and that is going to be a title
item this time and over here i'm just
going to say i just need a completion as
well that is going to be escaping
and that is just going to give me like
um the same result that i had
all right so the result is going to be
um
void
and error all right
so basically this is going to be the
function that i'm going to get a title
item over here so i just need to have
like the same reference for the app
delegate and the
um database manager
so let me just have that
so
um i'm gonna be asking the data manager
or basically the database manager hey
context please delete object and that is
going to be the model
and over here i'm just going to do a
catch block so that i can commit
those uh changes inside my database so
right here i'm just
asking
the database manager
to delete
certain
object
and over here i'm just saying okay
confirm deletion so basically let me
just type try context.save
and over here the completion is just
going to be success which is basically
going to be avoid again and for the
catch i'm just going to
say completion dot failure and let me
just pass a new error over here so
case failed
to
delete data
and let me pass that over here so
basically database error dot failed to
delete data basically that's it
all right let me just delete that
comment i don't need that you understand
that
so um let me just go to my collection
table view cell over here and let me
implement one more function
and that function is going to allow us
actually to delete something from a
table and that function should be called
like commit i believe so let me just say
yeah that's not right so um yeah i
believe it's in the download controller
i'm really sorry about that so
um that is going to be commit
editing style so i'm just going to
switch on the editing style and case
delete so basically if the user is
attempting to delete an item
basically i just need first to remove
that from the table so table view
all right so remove or delete i believe
so delete rows at uh index paths so this
is going to be an array of index path
and for the animation i'm just going to
say like fade i believe that's the one
and over here i just need to delete that
from the um
from the database itself so let me just
say
data persistence manager share dot
delete title with the model of titles
all right so that is going to be index
path dot row and for the completion i'm
just going to say switch
on the result
case success basically i don't get
anything so print
deleted
from the
database and over here for the failure
so failure let me get the error
and again print
error dot localize description
i believe that is going to be working so
um
all right so yeah we just need to have
like another
case uh after the delete over here so
basically that is going to be default
and for the default i just need to break
i don't need to do anything else
so um basically let me just replace and
hit build and run let me see that myself
so basically i have two instances of
spider-man over here so let me just
you know use that and i can see here
that i'm getting an error
all right so invalid number of rows so
yeah i might be you know like um
making something before something so let
me just go back to the download
controller and i'm just going to delete
that row after
actually i like um
remove that from the database so let me
just hit build and run one more time and
i believe that is going to work so all
right so right so right now i know the
error basically we forgot actually to
remove that as well from the titles
array over here so let me just say um
titles dot remove at and i'm just going
to pass in the index path the row i
believe that is going to work uh yeah we
just need to have like a week reference
for the title so we excel
and over here i'm just going to say self
which is going to be an optional self
let me hit build and run one more time
and i believe that is going to work uh
basically yeah we just need to yeah
basically this is just ridiculous
so let me just go back to download view
controller let me just
try to do this first so um
okay i'm just going to remove that from
the array and then delete that from the
table
i don't have anything over here so let
me just download that one more time it's
not there yet i'm just going to fix that
really quick
and then let me just
open the app one more time we have
spiderman let me just delete that and
yes this is working so basically this is
the
way that we are going to be deleting
things so basically we're just deleting
it from the database once and for all
and first we're just going to remove the
title from the array itself then from
the table view itself so now we have a
problem
basically whenever we
download something in here basically we
just need to
have something that notifies the
download um controller to actually fetch
or basically reload itself so that it
you know when you tap download inside
the home view controller it's already
there in the download tab so basically
this is what we're going to be doing
right now using something called the
notification center and that has nothing
to do with the notification center on
your device basically that is pure swift
thing
so basically um we're just you know or
i'm just going to show you how that
works so um let me just go back to my um
all right so collection table view cell
and over here once i'm done with
downloading to database so let me just
go in here in case of the success and
over here i'm just going to say
notification center dot
i believe default
and here i'm just going to post
a notification so let me just do that so
post
all right so basically let me just put
post a notification
i'm really sorry so post a notification
with a name so
um ns notification name so i'm just
going to pass in here something like
down
loaded so basically i'm just going to
post uh a downloaded notification across
the app and over here i'm just going to
pass nil i don't need to pass anything
else so whenever the
title is downloaded i'm just going to
notify
everyone who is listening to that
notification so i have completed my
download or basically download it all
right so over here inside the download
view controller
i just need um to do this so basically i
just need to listen for the changes that
happens so let me just say notification
center dot default dot add observer and
for the observer i'm just going to
listen for the same
name or of the notification that i
posted which is basically downloaded
all right and for the object i'm going
to be passing nil
cue
nil
and for the method that i'm going or
basically the method that i'm going to
trigger so basically that is going to be
self
dot
all right and that is going to be
um
fetch local storage
and basically that's it i believe we
need to make a weak reference or yeah
that is okay i believe
so um yeah i believe that is okay so let
me just hit build and run and let me see
if i do actually have it so
right now i don't have anything inside
my downloads so let me just try to
download spiderman one more time
download over here and when i i and here
we go boom whenever i go to downloads i
have spiderman is waiting for me
we can just try anything else so maybe
the matrix
so let me just download that and let me
just go in here boom we have the matrix
as well
so basically
i have everything set up i just need to
have like a handler for that as well so
let me just go back to my upcoming and
for the did select at row i'm gonna be
copying everything from here i'm gonna
go to the download controller let me
just paste that over here hit building
right and i believe that is going to
work so downloads we have spiderman let
me just click on it and i believe that
is going to take me directly to the um
to the preview controller that we have
over here so
i guess this is going to be the last
video of this series it's been too long
and if you've been following the series
up till now
i can't thank you enough because you've
been like a huge supporter for me so
once again thank you so much guys i
believe this is going to be the end of
this series so again thank you so much
for sticking around if you liked what
you just saw please hit that like button
and consider subscribing to my channel
because that is going to be helping me
big time and hit that like button you
know that is going to help me as well
with the youtube algorithm and let me
just catch you in the next tutorials or
maybe in the next series to be exact so
once again that was armed please have a
good day and stay safe